I don't know what you're gonna do as far as literally no way to know what's happening.
No, no, no, Lou.
There's gonna be explosions.
Yeah, you'll know.
I don't know.
You're gonna see shit off.
Wait, explosions?
What did you do that much?
I mean, this is gonna be--
I'm trying to fight.
Baptiste and a church on fire.
Yeah.
I literally started a prison riot.
Yeah, there's gonna be some chaos.
I'm just gonna be sent a dog to get Bob.
No, we sent the dog to get back on the ship because it's--
Yeah, yeah.
It's sort of to get Bob then.
Yeah, probably.
I'll say we'll say.
All right, everyone in.
When you guys can come in at your pace,
OK.
It's maybe around afternoon or something.
Bob, you notice some commotion at the deck of the ship.
And you hear--
Paid call your name.
Well, he's gonna go out and check.
OK, you arrive at the deck.
I don't know if you witnessed what was happening
or where you were when you arrived at the deck,
but I guess you guys decided that Bob will look after the ship.
As you come outside, you see what's his name?
Kade is holding Lu in his arms.
And you see there's like a scratch on one of his paws.
And Kade is trying to look over that.
He looks at you, as he says.
Lu won't come back if the captain was in trouble.
That's the only reason he'd send Lu away.
Maybe I should leave and try to figure out what is happening.
You should not do that, dude.
We need someone on the ship.
How about you, the one who is our helmsman,
stay on the ship to get the other escape derker.
And I go and check, OK?
OK, I think that will work.
I'll see if Drago's is feeling any better or not.
He takes Lu and heads like under the deck to check on Drago's.
It's up to you to leave.
He points you to the stairway that Malfa's in the back.
He's standing over there.
So I guess he just snuck in through that mansion.
Unnoticed.
But you'll have to make your way outside.
That's not going to be easy.
Well, and is there smoke coming on the--
Again, you're like in an underground channel where your ship is.
It's all underground.
So you don't see anything that is just a big cave.
And your ship is just anchored there.
Well, well, you go.
There's no other way then.
I mean, you can try going this straight channel,
because the channel is leading straight as well.
But it's up to you, whichever way you want to take the stairs.
You want to--
Straight channel.
Yeah, the cave is going underneath this.
This is the first place.
But you can like sail the ship forward as well to check where it goes.
But it's up to you.
It's your decision.
Well, they might come back in this route.
And if the ship is not there, they might think it's putt again.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he's probably going to go in this to the stairway.
You head up the stairway.
The gates are a little bit cracked open,
because Lou just squeezed his way in through the door.
So you can see through and look at what is happening.
And you just see a bunch of chaos, a bunch of people
like walking around trying to figure out
like whatever is happening.
They're trying to secure the house down,
because there has been a parent here, prison break,
as you over here, some of the workers in the house talking.
Do they look at him?
Like do they notice him or anything?
No, you still within the door.
Do you want to leave?
Do you just want to go in?
Well, yes, he's going to go in.
There's doesn't seem to be any other way.
OK, you walk in and you see a bunch of guards just
point their guns towards you as they start moving close
as they--
who are you?
How'd you find your way back there?
From that door.
What?
How many guards by the way just asking?
Three or four guards?
Yeah, he's going to go in front of them
and go like up to a random door and go.
I just came from there.
And the moment they look at them,
he will try to make a run outside the house.
I mean, again, you're standing in front of the door
behind this stale way.
There is no room to leave other than whichever way
they are facing.
So they won't let you move.
They have their guns pointed at you.
You'll have to convince them.
[AUDIO OUT]
Jefferson.
This person just seemed like an kindly prisoner.
He might have escaped from the imperial coast.
Excuse me.
Oh, what do you think I look like?
What's on my-- one don't mean makes you think I am a prisoner.
Did it flash?
Oh, you don't seem to do very well.
Anyway, how did you enter through the channel?
Are there more people behind you?
If so, just come quietly.
Look, look, look.
There has been so many chaos going on,
and I just wanted to check.
Like what exactly?
You see why there is so much chaos in this house.
This isn't your house.
Why are you here?
I wanted to help, man.
Help, who?
We can take care of ourselves.
Who are you?
Why are you here?
Yeah, I was just passing by, and there
was so much chaos, and I thought someone died or something.
And I can heal people.
I am like a doctor.
So I just came here just seeing if anyone has a heart attack
or something.
Can you roll a deception for me?
I'll just say it.
I don't know.
Well, can he do like a Sherlock Holmes
and smoke his bonfire?
He is trying to tell them that.
Yeah, sure.
All right, so let me do that.
It's damage.
Mame.
Oh, my God.
It's a little bit beautiful.
He does not believe you.
The guard starts to move closer.
And he goes.
I need you to put your hands up and on your knees now.
OK, sir. He probably does that and goes, OK, if you just
tell me if there is anyone injured, I can do it.
That I am actually a healer.
You can take that chance right now.
You're going to be sent to the prison
and will identify you if you are one of the prisoners or not.
Until then, stay put.
All right, then.
I'm fine with that.
OK, he signals to another guard.
And the guard comes around.
He takes like a pair of cuffs.
And he tries to put the cuffs on you.
Do you want to resist or no?
No.
OK, he puts the cuffs on you as he puts the gun down.
The guard that was pointed the guard and gun at you.
The other two guards come around behind you, grab you,
and start to take you out the mansion and put you in one
of the wagon.
Gentle breeze.
Yeah, yeah, whatever.
The shall view inside this wagon.
Talk to the doctor over here.
Uh-huh.
OK.
All right, take him in.
The people like riding the wagon,
get the horse as you start leaving.
OK, I'm going to shift to Roma at this point.
OK, Roma, you land on your ass while you fell through the ceiling
and you find yourself in one of the cells.
Roma?
Is he on here?
It's so funny that the moment Roma's
P.O.V. starts, he just falls right at the light.
What even is that?
Oh, you don't know.
Yeah, I remember.
I remember.
Roma.
Roma, Roma.
Ready, go.
I'm not here.
He's unfoundary.
Let me go.
Yo, can you--
we can't hear you if you're--
You can't hear me?
Yeah.
OK, well, shit.
Let me just connect or reconnect my mic.
This whole time I'm talking.
I'm like, I'm--
Yeah.
We couldn't hear you at all.
OK, let me--
I'll see you there.
I think there's some problem with the mic, maybe.
Just disconnect and reconnect.
I think it might be just the--
we see.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah.
Now we can hear you.
OK.
So last time, as you were being chased
by the recruit armored Marines,
you fell through the floor and you find yourself in the cell.
And one of the cells that you freed some prisoners from.
Can I use my dark sense to see if--
Yeah, the room is kind of lit.
You see a pair of hands come out of the left wall.
As you start to see the full figure as he walks straight
through the wall and heads inside,
you see it is lineth.
As you look at-- as you look at you and goes,
well, I do not expect to see you here, my friend.
What the fuck?
Where the fuck have you been?
We've been trying to call.
We've been writing.
No response.
First off, first off, first off, time out.
We go rewind this.
House Abla.
Yeah.
What's--
About her.
I did find Nikolai's lab.
And I did find some research that he was working on.
And sadly, unfortunately, was one of her subjects.
She-- I didn't tell her a lot about this,
but I have entrusted her to one of my friends.
She's been sent to Zoh.
And I hope she will recover.
The monks living there might have some kind of solution.
You said her--
You said her to a place where they teach cooking.
No, no, the high monks are--
You're from Zoh.
I know the high monks.
Their specialty is cooking.
Yeah, there's some healers there,
but they specialize in cooking techniques.
He puts his hand around, Jehinkos.
It's fine.
I know someone, and he's been looking after her.
Oh, no, no.
Who is that someone?
He used to be part of the six vaults, but he
apparently lives back at Zoh.
What's his name?
Asha.
I don't know.
We shouldn't be waiting here for long.
So--
Well, I--
What?
Yeah?
Do I still have the keys?
You do, you do.
The cell is open.
All of the cell cells are still open.
I got it.
Yeah.
Anyway, I saw you through the crowd,
and I thought I could help you out.
No?
You should be adding out now.
I don't--
Perthable.
Why?
There's somebody on a ship that we got to rescue.
I don't remember who to be exactly,
but boss man's here too, someplace.
But we're here to rescue somebody.
The Baptiste is here as well.
Baptiste, we got another fellow with wings.
His name is Malfus.
I call him Zapdos from time to time.
And then we got another fellow--
his name is Bob.
I can't describe Bob, but me and Bob, like, we think of the thieves.
You know what I'm saying?
Me and Bob, we got this relationship.
Or we--
Let's calm down.
We just get into shit.
I think we just get into shit.
We'll catch up.
I don't think that there's the right time to do so.
Anyway.
But motherfucker, I missed you.
Well, I'm glad that we met each other.
I'm just going to--
Roman's just going to go in for a hug.
He's just going to straight pick up the doctor, like--
Oh.
As you try to grab him, he just phases through and he goes--
Roman.
Calm down.
I understand that it has been a while.
And you're excited.
But we need to figure out the situation here.
A bunch of the prisoners have taken down
the guards that were protecting the people.
And now I think we'll have to maybe
print down the fact.
No, no.
So the guards were anybody who did a crime,
even if they didn't have proof of the crime.
They just arrested people.
Found that out.
Because there are several innocent people here.
So I freed them.
Roman, I don't know how to tell you this,
but a lot of those people were actually
bandits and pirates.
And those people--
Yeah, that's fine.
We have to subdue them.
We will, just let people die.
We won't.
We will.
But we got to rescue them.
We got to rescue the person first.
They're on a ship.
They're on the warship.
You mean the warship so long side the island?
Yes.
They're on one of them.
And let's just say it's probably
going to be the one with the most people on it.
Boy, Ravens is not here if that's who you're looking for.
I expected the old man to send someone.
I didn't expect you to show up.
But--
Sorry, I'm sorry.
I think it's either--
I was about to say, Dr. Davos is on a warship.
I believe it's Dr. Davos.
He meant to say Dr. Davos.
I have to argue.
I can't.
Dr. Davos, I remember.
Dr. Davos, I believe, might be one of them.
But I think it's also--
so remember Zapdos, I was talking about.
It may be a sister.
I don't remember which ones on the island.
We're here to say one of them.
No?
Oh, yeah.
I believe it's-- I believe it's drove in, is on this island.
But it might be Zapdos' sister.
I don't remember.
It's wonderful.
I'm usually cooking.
You know how--
Going after the warships is probably not ideal.
I don't-- but the reason I'm here
is I'm looking for someone that they're
recently captured.
And she was supposed to be--
like a hearing tomorrow for her crimes.
But--
Yeah.
I was trying to get some info where she could be.
I didn't--
She's also on the ship.
See that Vorra was here.
So that's not good.
And his old battalion is supposedly also here.
The people that were after you are part of Zoro's unit.
So--
Yes.
Maybe we try to capture one of them and ask some questions.
No, I'll find out about the--
OK.
Are you sure that's the ship that--
You said the people after me were--
You said the people after me were on--
were his guards.
Well, those people came from a ship that is literally
at the end of--
I'm going to describe the area where I saw this ship.
It's like you go down these tunnels left, right down.
And it's a big, giant area where the worships
parked up against the dock.
They all came from that.
The reason I know they came from that
is because I tried to knock out a dude.
He pounded it on the side of the ship.
And 30 motherfuckers jumped off that ship.
And I took off a run.
[LAUGHS]
Who night? So I guess leave the way.
We can't because they are coming from that area.
Give them five minutes to start working their way
through the prison.
And then we can go because they're not going to be over.
They're not going to go back to the ship just quite yet.
They're going to try to get this shit under control.
We can't stay here until we can come after us.
I saw some people getting down.
All right, we'll head out and find them.
Yeah, we just got to wait five minutes.
We got to give them chance to get up the stairs
and start making their way through the prison.
And then we can try to sneak past them.
You know what I'm saying?
Stealthy James Bond style.
All right.
OK, while this is happening, I'm
going to switch to about peace and mattresses now.
Yep.
We go to the crossroads.
All right.
Can you guys see?
Rest in peace.
It's still low.
Oh no.
I got 96%.
I'm old 98.
98.
I have a question.
I have a stupid search bar now that has popped up.
How do I get rid of that?
I think it's space.
Space, yeah.
Ship space.
Thank you.
I don't know how to hold that popped up.
All right.
This is fucking hilarious.
You guys in?
No, I'm reloading.
OK.
Still voting.
The map is still loading.
I'll just do a good load.
No, you don't.
Oh, 98%.
Find for me.
How many-- what's the-- what's the pen for you guys?
I'll go to the edge because I'm loading.
OK.
190.
Oh, I see. I have like 80 or something.
That's why.
Oh.
Yeah, there's three points.
I mean, it will be at one.
Oh, I'm in.
All right.
You're in.
My whole screen just won't black.
Wait, is there-- let me check.
Token vision shouldn't be a problem.
You should be able to see restrict visibility
within the scene to the vision of the control tokens
if disabled being seen as visible.
It should be visible to everyone.
No, everything is black.
There's nothing like no chance.
There's no UI.
Oh, yeah, I think it's just you just reloaded.
Because for me, it shows that--
Baptiste is here.
And none of the other people are here yet.
Bob, you're still on Lexington, pier ourselves.
I'll--
Is this tree loading again?
This man is his carriage.
I love the carriage.
It's essentially a car.
Did he not bring--
OK.
Let me see if I can just bring everyone home.
Pull all players to the scene.
I just don't have a UI.
It takes a while.
Just stay there for a while.
I think it loads up.
Another bit.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Normal reaches 5B, right, for attacks.
Yep.
What?
No, it's just double checking something.
Oh, you lost connection to the server,
or something to reestablish.
Goddamn it.
I was working fine there.
That's fine.
OK, somebody else got that error message too?
Yeah, yeah.
I just got it.
Yeah, there must be something going on with Foundry.
Yeah, it's fine, it's fine.
It will fix itself, hopefully.
And I have to pull out a D20.
Do the soul school, where--
I don't have my sights on me.
[LAUGHS]
Oh, we could always use the role for chaos for stuff,
but it's just like the character sheets are.
The problem.
Yeah.
I need the right stuff down.
Just to get stuff like that happens.
Yeah.
Or export it somewhere.
And it's completely black, though, for me now.
Not Goddamn it.
[LAUGHS]
What's working fine yesterday?
How long did I spend the last time?
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
Don't stop.
For me, oh, it's just down now.
Yeah.
OK.
I think it should be up.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
You have to restart.
Found it.
I'm just restarting.
OK.
I can't hear a code.
Yeah, that's me.
I'm restarting it that's why.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
So there we go.
Should work now.
OK.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
Can you all see something?
No, no, yeah.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
Oh, they've logged in, yeah.
I did log in, yeah.
I'm just waiting.
It's just a fucking black screen.
So the thing, oh, I can log in.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
God, what the fuck?
Maybe whenever I switch scenes,
that's when it fucking destroys itself.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
What is happening?
What is the Star Wars-ass music?
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
The boss music.
I don't do anything.
Let me pause it.
Hey, Voro was- oh my god.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
All right.
Nice.
So there has to be something going on with Foundry.
It's my Foundry, yeah.
That's the problem.
It's running on this fucking small ass raspberry.
I thought it would be fine, but I guess it's not working out.
Do I have anything else running on it?
Let me check.
I'm just stopping everything else.
You got like 30 different things running on it?
No, I don't think so.
It's mostly Foundry.
It might be...
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
So Bob, how have you been?
It's been two weeks.
Three, technically.
[MUSIC - "HELLO"]
No two.
Only three.
Great.
He wasn't there for the last one.
Oh, sister's to see.
I have a question.
Yeah.
No, this is for Bob.
I don't know if he can hear me.
If his...
Does his barn still give him the euphoric, like, high feeling?
Or does it just buff him?
It's not exactly a bone like a curse.
It's like a curse, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
But again, since it is cursed, my next two checks are going to be with disadvantage.
So that kind of makes it like, I am new for you.
Perfect.
My type of puzzle piece.
Oh, Bob, you got a new hobby.
Also, you really haven't used your smoking something.
You haven't really used that.
My size sure?
Yeah.
That's because all it does is give me an air...
Elementals, yeah.
Yeah.
So I got to have a reason to use my air elemental.
Bob, you also miss it a lot.
We get a new bounty.
Yeah, please don't help me okay. I'm back in are you guys back in just I'm just gonna play any music player your own music. I think the music is fucking everything up
The Marine inside was
second rate
I
Update part this been to six whatever I begin encounters your chair now just
But these are just fish targets
Well, it's not matter. I just
Looking the other options I mean again, you can always do all of this in character
If you don't have to talk above the board about this
I'm taking half your movement speed. Yes, it does
Did I can't get over this time then?
You could back and all the stash
Then I can't swing
Come up we're having all right
Let me roll that the eight
We can stand seven seven I think seven is good
We'll text roles against you are made to disappear. Oh nice
Yeah, but what should I be like a plus a billion?
Yeah, I'll keep for a busy
20 7 when seven will head let go
Look at that low damage
Yeah, it just damage
That's all that matters that's actually very good
And another one I guess
Get seven all right no it won't hit
You
Dash in as you punch
Warrow right in the chest twice
He slides back a little bit. It looks back at you as you
Dash back away from him. He looks at you and he goes
Done with you your crew
Black hand and all of you pirates and he's gonna burn his legendary action
And he's gonna
Finger best all
This advantage oh
My god, it wasn't that 20 holy shit
He dashes straight towards you and he just smacks you right in the chest
Let me first you did 11 damage right
Let me do that and
It's not arranged
Yeah finger pistol in one piece is you know
Luchie stabs him right
It's not his not what do you mean it's it's a Roku Shiki technique
It's a flick
Yeah, it's essentially like what he does like
In quotes his finger with hockey and then stabs you
Glutie
All right 14
So you have because I get three you get three backs so that will be 11
So that is for some yeah for some reason I still does give me three time base BF E fucking turns
I'll add three back just in case yeah
There we go he
Stabbs you once right in the chest as he starts to close in
More and more
It's gonna be
His turn
next is the machine and he will
Dives trade in and try to take you out
Map taste
We will the ground 19
That's
Jesus
So he charges up you see it flying hovering over you as he just turns around drops all of his like the jet booster that he has going on and just the whole metal body starts to just
Ghost right down and he pushes
His fists in front as that smacks into you as a shockwave ripples out
You can also hear like the
Just yeah
All right, it's your turn no, it's worse. No, it's your turn. No, it's about this. Yeah, sorry
Let me give you
So
I'm already lost because I'm not half HP and I
Let's see what I can do
You still have inspiration right no, you do have inspiration points. I think you oh
No, he used one already against the gate. Yeah, he should still have one. Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, he should have one
Yeah, he destroyed that gate
No, no after that gate all of you when you fought your one V1s you get get one
Inspiration I think
Yeah
You use both of those I thought you only used the one the two got one in the game
Oh, yeah, yeah
Yeah, but then after you after that you get one right?
Everyone who has not used one has three right now
Sorry, two two two everyone has two except for Baptiste who had three and now he has one
That's
Well this action
And the domain
I need my resistances
How are you on
So are you gonna use my double fruit to get that verb save it for shields
Hello
What could be bone
Using all three double brooks uses
It is now I
Used one actual one bonus I get one of two attacks
That right to a text yeah, sounds right
I didn't do my actual arms oh well one punch
Oh
It's moving kind of slow
I lost connection oh god
One of the way everything was moving so slow there we go
Yeah, I think a little take five seconds for it to load in yeah
It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. We'll live I think I
Think the CPU is overloading I think that's why
Why is it doing that though it should be
So is it back
For me either
Now I'll try to figure this shit out the next time
Hmm
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You know what thing I can't log in.
It doesn't say that you're in.
>> And, one again.
>> He's gone again?
>> Yeah, but I just basically did.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> There's been doing this ever since I upgraded.
Back in.
>> All right, just make your two attacks quickly.
Quickly.
>> Ford precious.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Fall food attack it.
>> Before.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> When he doesn't hit 24 heads.
>> What the fuck are we?
>> It's a fucking arm.
What do you mean?
>> What do you mean?
>> Let's do a little worse than that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right, what's the content?
There we go.
>> It's armor and it hides a high con.
Oh my god.
>> And team.
>> A armor with plus four cons.
>> Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I think even without the plus four,
he would have rolled 15.
Just higher.
>> Yeah, yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> That's my turn.
>> All right, just after your turn,
the armor starts to power up outside of its hand.
You see the laser charges up as he is going to make his
reaction and two palm lasers.
>> How does laser melee?
>> It's not melee.
It's going to be with disadvantage.
>> The battery.
>> 18 and another one with disadvantage.
>> 19.
>> 19 doesn't miss.
>> Yes, it does.
He has haste.
>> Oh, he does have haste, never mind.
All right, as both of these charges blasts straight
through you.
And you stand up.
It's going to be his turn.
>> Quickly so her eyes will I live.
>> And now it's, what's his turn?
>> So, please, Crash, I want to live.
>> You're looking better than me right now.
>> Oh, give it a second.
>> He's going to,
he's going to, he's going to, he's going to, he's going to, he's going to.
>> Okay, trying to end this quite quickly.
He's just going to do a cool gun.
Okay, can you make a?
>> Remember what disadvantage?
>> It's not, it's not an attack roll.
I can make a con.
>> Oh, shit.
>> I don't tell me disconnect.
>> That's just 12.
>> Okay.
So, this is where either you die.
>> Oh, you live.
It really, really depends.
>> Love those choices.
>> He places both of his hands right in front of you as he's going to send like a big shock
with right in your chest.
And it's going to be.
>> How many of the roll?
>> Question.
>> Shockwave, would that be like electricity damage?
>> It's going to be.
>> It's going to be thunder.
>> No, no.
>> 36.
>> So, that's going to be three.
And then, 36 would be 33, right?
>> No, 36.
The temperature is, it starts on my turn.
>> Oh, so you don't have the temperature right now.
>> What is going on, bitch?
>> As he essentially like slams you with the shockwave, you go flying in 20 feet back.
>> It's just 20 feet.
>> And he's going to give chase.
>> And he's going to close the distance again.
>> That was 40 feet.
>> No, no.
That is 20.
What do you mean?
>> The first 20 that it shows is for your movement.
>> Yeah, total 40.
>> My character was on the 22.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, right around this time.
Right around this time, Bob, you starts to, the wagon that was carrying you starts to come up this direction.
>> And it's not like any other road except for the house.
>> He was literally going to your palace, so no.
>> There we go.
>> But you're tied up right now.
>> Why do you have to kill me as well?
>> You're already dead.
>> No, he's having a good circle.
>> As some of the guards jump out and try to assess the situation, the water looks back and he goes, go away.
>> This is marine business.
Don't not interfere.
All right, it's your turn, Melvus.
He's distracted right now.
You can do whatever you want with the advantage.
>> What up, Bob?
>> It's crazy.
>> Pants him.
>> You're the old dick, Bob.
>> You kind of hear like Baptiste and Melvus talk outside.
>> I am inside the thing, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You don't even know where I am.
>> You don't know where I am.
>> I see a guy that can kill me when I know.
>> You haven't seen him yet.
You're still in the wagon.
>> I do hear them screaming in pain.
I know that I can kill me.
>> I see a guy who can kill me.
>> He's going great.
>> Oh, God.
>> It's okay.
>> No, no.
>> No, it might be possible for me to just.
>> No, but it's going to take a while.
>> God damn it.
>> His fight is giving me flashbacks
of the first couple encounters.
Everyone has a legendary experience.
>> I did warn you.
>> Well, the first couple encounters
who we fight,
circuit well followed by fighting Voro.
>> Yeah.
>> That's the first that clips though.
>> Exactly.
>> We fucked up those spiders pretty quick though.
>> Yeah.
>> If it's a flashback, does it mean
it's a real issue up right now?
>> I don't think so.
>> What do you mean?
>> You can expect an NPC to show up
whenever you fuck up the situation.
>> I already brought,
I already bought Bob in.
It's just two people coming.
>> Bro, Bob does wait too much damage.
What the hell do you mean?
>> I just want to die at peace.
>> Whatever.
>> I don't want to look at Bob that face.
>> Bob is already talking about staying in the freaking wagon.
>> Yes.
>> Oh yeah, I'll tell you the truth.
>> Yeah, Bob doesn't know me, I'm safe.
>> Yeah, okay.
[ Music ]
>> I'm trying to maybe just start it here.
>> Yeah.
[ Music ]
[ Silence ]
>> Oh, I'm back in.
Are you in?
[ Silence ]
>> Yeah.
>> I smashed a couple of guards.
>> Yeah, but that was on not on the phone.
I guess you did make some rolls.
I also need to maybe clear up some stuff.
I think it's just piling up.
[ Silence ]
>> I love you.
>> Only Malthus is not in there.
>> I'm still loading.
>> I still got the blank screen.
>> We need to know pineapple under the sea.
>> I'm supposed to have dark video.
>> You're not the only one brother.
>> Yeah, you can see inside the wagon, but not outside.
You can wash through walls, right?
>> I can't.
>> You're just niggling.
>> I'm not spying.
>> You're not spying.
>> I feel a disturbance in the forest.
>> Pop must be nearby.
>> No, that's just you dreaming.
>> I smell a bob around.
>> Does anyone else smell rotting flesh?
>> No.
[ Silence ]
>> God, I don't do this to me, man.
>> I can't hear you.
[ Silence ]
>> There we go.
>> Everyone will roll in quickly.
>> We got to blitz this encounter.
>> Yeah, we're fighting the fucking foundry.
>> Come back.
>> Everybody pass pace.
>> 147, yeah.
147, 20.
The ram is fine.
I don't know what is happening, man.
>> I deducted his HP.
>> Yeah.
>> I hit him one, so hit him again.
>> I'm sick.
>> I have no ride.
>> You already used your bonus in action, so this is your last one, I think.
>> I'm using my bonus action yet.
What are you talking about?
>> 20, let's go.
>> Yeah, for transform.
[ Silence ]
>> It's 10, for this 30.
>> Plus 3, right?
>> Yeah, plus 6.
>> Plus 9 is 18.
>> 18.
>> Yeah, the squid is one dice next, right?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> 18.
>> Just don't fucking crash, please.
There we go.
All right, as you transform back, you take all the lightning that you channeled
from your transformation and just burst him with that lightning strike as the ground shakes
and the reverberations can be heard through the doors of the wagon.
Bob, if you want to make your move, you can.
Otherwise, you'll have to wait another turn.
>> I'm strong, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And I do have my algorithm, right?
>> They would take it away and store it somewhere in the wagon.
>> Away from you.
>> I still have my muscles.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> I don't know.
>> You can write a pen because my disturb you shit.
>> That's fine.
>> You can make a strength check to break the cuffs.
Nope.
>> Nice.
>> I'm not going to do it.
>> Go back to the --
>> As you try to struggle out of the chains, the chains do not give just yet.
So you can try pulling next time.
All right, now this.
Now, the arbor will start to --
>> This house can bust.
>> [humming]
>> Okay.
Baptiste, as you turn around and strike him, the armor kind of steps back.
And you see that the energy starts to focus in the visor of the armor.
You see that the light starts to glow brighter and brighter near the head gap where the visor of the armor is.
>> Okay.
>> That's safe.
>> Dex.
>> I have a damage.
>> 23.
>> Okay.
>> You can take half of this damage.
>> As this beam of energy, just straight up energy, just strikes you right in the face.
This is going to be radiant damage so you don't have resistance to it.
So half of this is 16.
>> The flake missile.
>> You can deflect missile.
>> Let's go.
>> It's not a flavored as a beam but essentially it's like -- it's not an attack roll, but sure.
>> It just needs to be 11.
You just need to be more than 11.
>> 12.
Yeah, you negate the complete -- not complete damage.
It's 32, right?
It's 32, after 16.
>> You take four damage.
>> I was looking at it 23.
>> Yeah, that's the next thing.
Wait.
Wait, what?
>> What?
>> You succeeded.
Okay, what the fuck am I looking at?
Yeah.
>> 12.
That will only hit you 4/4.
So essentially as he beams you with that laser, you slide downwards as it just goes up.
>> That's the first.
>> It's just like this.
>> That's the third.
>> As it just graces you from the shoulder or something.
>> So you only take four damage.
>> 20.
>> There we go.
>> All right, that's going to be its churn.
Also, can you make a concentration?
>> [inaudible]
>> Is it the current check, right?
>> Yeah, it's all safe.
>> Conceived.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Okay, you still have haste on.
Forget.
>> The early.
>> Next is you, Baptiste.
>> Go, Baptiste.
>> Fuck it up.
>> Oh, good move.
>> I'm looking pretty rough.
I'm not going to lie.
But where there's a will, there's a way.
>> There is a will.
>> There is no will.
>> Okay, that's the one.
Test the waters out.
I wish I would do my other punch.
>> Are you at 20?
>> No, I'm not.
>> I'm not going to lie.
>> So that's 21 damage.
It was just one point off.
Max rolling it anyways.
>> This force.
>> This force damage, right?
>> I'm going to make a con save.
>> Right.
>> And 20.
>> Oh my god.
Of course.
>> So I'm going to activate the ass alarms.
>> W.
>> That's bonus, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> Okay.
I need to make a safe.
>> Why could have got four limits?
>> He fails.
So do the damage and he'll be pushed 10 feet.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So you can do the damage and the damage and the damage.
>> So that's your ass alarms form in the impact from which they form throws the armor away.
And that will do 10 damage and 10, 20.
>> Okay.
>> Sit back in.
>> Sit down.
>> Get up.
>> No.
>> 16,000 head.
>> 19 hits.
>> Didn't 20 missed before?
>> Yeah, but the armor suit us down.
>> Oh.
>> You're deteriorating it.
>> Essentially every time it uses the energy, the --
it has to wait a couple of rounds to regain this strength.
>> It fails.
>> Yeah.
>> You needed that.
I did all my attacks.
One, two, three.
Yeah, I'm done.
>> All right.
What was the --
>> I didn't --
>> Damage.
Yeah, I rolled the damage.
>> 12.
>> That one needs to be --
>> That's going to be four straight.
>> All right.
>> As the first punch, as you throw it to the head,
the head kind of bangs, but so it doesn't go through.
The second hit you throw right at the chest,
and the armor starts to crack a little bit,
as the force actually impacts whatever --
whoever's wearing the armor,
that will do 2012 damage.
And next is --
>> After your turn.
>> Borough.
>> Looks at you.
And he goes --
a zone type.
So that's how you were following me.
[laughs]
>> Let me see if he has regenerated the --
>> Yeah, what now?
>> 16.
>> The --
>> The what now?
>> Pretty no.
>> He did it, right?
Uh --
two --
>> Yeah, he steps back a bit as he throws these vendous lashes
from his leg.
Make a --
make a --
save, yeah.
>> Wait, one.
>> One, you can take half of this damage.
>> One, two, three.
>> One, three.
>> Five, six, seven.
>> Eleven.
>> Can I get through?
>> Again, this is not an attack role.
So you can do this, like, missile, right?
So, you know what?
>> Sure.
>> For now, yes.
But don't take this as, like, a rule.
It won't work like this.
>> I won't.
>> Okay.
>> So that's 11 damage, yeah.
>> I'm still in my 10.
It's fine.
>> So, 10, 14, yeah.
There we go.
Uh -- he looks at you and he goes,
"No matter what you do,
you will not escape from me this time.
You or your captain are going to pay
for all these inconvenience that you've caused us.
The commander is not happy about what you've done
to Kalisto."
>> Is there anything?
>> Okay.
It's going to be his turn.
>> All right, it's your turn, Mel.
Um, Melphus, Bob, you can also try to escape
if you want to.
Make another strength.
Yeah, that should be able to bring the cops, yeah.
>> Okay, do I see my stuff?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, I take the immense rolling Melphus, just to --
>> -- that you can get into --
combat.
>> Yes, you're my initiative modifier.
>> Well, minus one, Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh, my God, you go after Warro.
Oh, my God.
I put his fucking thing at six.
That wasn't his actual initiative,
but I still did it.
Okay, place measured templates.
Where do you want to place the lightning bolt?
>> Like, both of those guys are in it.
And not that beast.
>> I don't see it, right?
>> I'm --
>> Okay, okay.
Let me --
>> Two dexaves, please.
>> There we go.
>> Okay, I think it's a little bit more.
>> The armor is --
>> The armor is done, so can he really make a dex?
>> Oh, yes, yes.
>> No, it can't.
It can't.
So, roll the damage.
>> Damn it.
86 in coming.
God damned us a lot of ones.
>> Of course, there's a lot of ones.
>> Why would there be a lot of ones?
>> Why would there be a lot of them?
>> So, he's keen, okay.
>> That's really low.
>> Yes, I run in eight.
>> There we go.
>> But what --
>> What's it's save, right?
So, it's going to be --
>> I don't know.
>> Was it --
>> Did he save or imagine that?
>> Yeah.
>> I rolled it right here, next save.
18, so I'll add nine back.
>> Yeah.
>> Nice.
>> Hey, baby.
>> My life.
>> You're going to die, right?
>> That's your turn, right?
>> You're not paying your dices in Foundy.
>> Like, you're probably possible.
>> We should do that.
>> Boro?
Boro, you can get --
I'll get you from this to get.
>> Not really.
>> I don't know.
>> Yes, I don't know.
>> Yeah, that's me.
I come to my boys' action to attack.
>> As you pivot and just throw like a big lightning bolt
toward him as it hits -- goes through Boro and hits the armor as well.
Boro stumbles back.
I think I've had enough.
>> Yeah, I mean, I'm going to get attacked.
>> Right now.
But that's advantage.
>> Disadvantage.
Disadvantage.
>> How did it get at 20?
>> 13.
Okay.
First one is a normal 20, right?
>> Yeah.
That is the other miss.
Okay.
That's going to be 20.
That will be -- so after your turn you gain three, right?
So that's going to be this and then you take a normal six.
>> I still have the 10 HP from the other thing.
>> Yeah, 14 and three, right?
So that's 17.
>> You can only have one source of 10 HP.
>> Oh, okay, okay.
So that's three more.
You're three HP.
Okay.
As he turns around and it just stabs you with his hockey and
coated finger three times again, right at your chest, one shoulder,
and on the other shoulder.
Did you do?
And you're profusely bleeding at this point.
You see?
>> I close the bang on.
I have five transformation ones.
>> Right.
>> After that.
>> The armor is going to make its move.
>> It's turned.
>> So it's -- at the end of the start of the turn.
>> I'm pleased with it.
>> It's turned.
>> It's not turned anymore.
Now it's your turn, Vaptis.
>> He is those guys.
>> What do you mean?
>> It's turned.
>> It's your next turn.
>> No, it is his next turn.
>> No, no, no, no.
>> Vaptis is nice.
>> The cost is very good.
>> Go ahead.
>> One.
>> Go ahead of Vanage.
>> 21 hits.
>> Good.
>> Well, doesn't hit.
>> First one is for Teen.
>> Three.
>> 22 hits.
Roll damage.
>> Isn't Vaptis able to get like six attacks since he has a --
>> Four.
>> Four, four.
>> No way.
It should be five with Flare of Load.
>> Is he using Flare of Us?
>> Exactly.
>> All right.
As you just throw all your astral punches one by one, chipping away
at the armor, the crack starts to break more and more pieces
off the armor.
You see inside of it, it's just a faceless person, like the
face is not there, whatever is inside is not human.
>> Mouthless is there again?
Disgusting.
>> No, no.
You already -- I don't know why I have to tell this again.
You already know that you're not there.
>> Yeah.
The Roman was just wrong.
>> Roman can be wrong.
Bob, you're not stupid.
>> Why intelligence has gone though?
>> Okay.
>> That's my turn.
>> All right.
After your turn, it's going to be War of --
>> Right, War of Finish is.
Just finish is.
>> And as you --
>> I did.
>> Yeah, I get your formation to be on me.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, at this point, he only has one thing.
>> It's what War of Finish wants to do.
He's going to grab you.
>> War of finish.
>> You can't just --
>> You know what?
He's going to be on a first knock you out.
Let me do that.
>> I want to play by all the characters.
>> You can't die until we find your sister, bro.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm the only one going down every fight.
>> You know what?
I'm going to --
>> Well, you're not.
>> No, you're not.
>> Yes.
>> If you die, you die, otherwise, you know, what can you do?
>> No, it's fine.
Honestly, I'm fine with it.
>> No, it's --
>> You have to --
>> It's for a reason.
>> No, it's for a reason.
>> Okay, but will that be part of my movement right now?
Because it's not my turn.
>> Yes.
>> It is your turn.
Was a, was a turn has ended technically.
>> Out, out.
I, I was really wishing that he did not take notice.
This 40 feet time move and this 40 feet.
>> Again, you are instilled around this area.
So like this area, because this is how big the cart
would be.
As soon as you step outside of it,
you will get spotted unless you have rolled like good stealth.
>> I would say, you have rolled like good stealth.
>> See if you are going to give me this.
Because if the cart is like, like two,
>> Like this.
>> It's looking toward this direction.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, and that's probably the door is probably there.
So can you say I was actually over here?
Right next to the door.
>> No.
>> Looking at what they are doing.
>> No, the door was in the behind here.
>> Yeah.
>> The cart went this way, right?
So it came from this way.
So the door would be behind the cart.
>> You are, there is no point.
Since I am still still, I'll just come over here.
>> No, no, you will have to make a stealth check.
You have armor, man.
>> You said I get still.
I don't know.
>> No, you have to roll for stealth with this advantage.
If you succeed, then yeah, otherwise they will notice you as soon as you come in,
like close vicinity.
Okay, that's good enough.
That's good.
>> Okay.
So since I'm already still, how far can I go without him noticing me?
Probably around, how much is your movement, 30 feet, right?
>> Yeah, 30 feet.
>> Yeah, you can go around to here, maybe behind this post or something.
>> Yes.
>> But after that, if you leave this post, they will notice you.
>> Okay, if you can't the end his turn so that my movement gets--
>> Okay, sorry, sorry.
>> There we go.
>> There you go.
And around over here, this is 30 feet.
So yeah, right behind this post, I really wish I could touch mouth.
>> No, don't be touching people.
>> Bob?
>> No, this turn, not the next turn.
>> Okay.
>> Bob, I don't give you permission to touch me.
>> That's not good sense, you all.
>> You cannot listen and right now.
With bonus action, I'll just do this because I can't touch mouth this right now.
>> I'll say it like that.
>> No, bonus is stealth, right?
>> What?
>> No, it's not bonus, it's just--
>> Yeah, hide is bonus.
>> To hide is an action except for a road.
>> Is it?
>> Yeah, I don't have the action.
>> Unless you're a rogue or something.
>> Okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Sorry, sorry, sorry.
>> I'm over there, I don't have my action.
And I just use--
>> How do I turn?
>> How do you turn?
>> I'm over there, I'm over there.
>> Sorry, sorry, sorry.
>> Wrong person.
>> Let me just turn it up.
>> Yeah, yeah, I turned it on.
And I don't have anything else.
>> I wanted to touch mouth this, but that's gonna--
>> What?
>> Now, you have to wait till next turn.
>> Don't be doing that.
>> I think we are not going to say that.
Never mind.
>> All right, next is--
>> It's your move, what do you want to do, Baptiste?
>> Yeah, it is a dead saving throw.
>> Dead save?
All right.
Aro privately.
>> Is that thing dead?
That he was fighting?
Because wouldn't it be that dude's fight?
>> No, no, no.
It was Bob's turn, so now it's Smylfus turn.
>> The armor is knocked out, right?
>> No, no, no.
>> No, it's not.
Who said it was?
>> I feel fucked.
>> Hmm, give me a sec.
>> Well, you have my blessing.
You're gonna roll it in that, Vinnie.
>> Hmm.
>> You just exceeding the first one?
>> Why'd you say it like that?
>> You should have told us that.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah, that's fucked.
I have no role in this.
>> No, no, no, no.
>> Okay.
>> He'll reenrolled.
I'm not going to tell what happened.
Okay?
Good?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, cool.
>> We just need a skull puff up on the mouth.
>> Don't worry, I know a guy that can rewrite that people.
You just, you'll just become, you'll just become a guy with rod and flesh.
>> Again, it's not like he can do it like 20 hours after the person has died.
He's not a fucking magician.
>> The mouth is when you want to meet him.
>> Also, you were a special case because you had the fucking core.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not like it's gonna happen for every character.
>> You're just a special boy.
>> Yeah.
>> What is a special thing?
>> Yeah, I'm happy.
>> All right.
It's the armor's turn.
It's going to start pointing its lasers to where it's you as it takes flight.
>> Truster burst.
There we go.
>> I don't have the normal version of this.
I'm rolling the legendary action, but he has the normal version.
It will fly up around here.
>> So it's leaving my range.
>> It's going to be a little bit of a bug.
>> By the way, after worst turn,
Bob, you can make your move, by the way.
>> Let's go ahead.
>> I'm going to touch you.
>> Let's do it.
>> All right.
>> Good rolls.
>> Let's go.
>> Okay, 23 heads.
>> It is going to use TechKai to get plus 3 AC.
>> That will not hit.
>> I would like to use my inspiration to add to the--
>> Okay.
>> Use your inspiration to add to the attack roll.
>> How do I just take away the inspiration?
>> Yeah, I just take away the inspiration.
>> Does it hit now?
>> Yes, it does hit now.
>> It's 18, and then I'm using my last beer point to try to stun them.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
>> He is not stunned, but he does take 18 damage.
>> I still have one more check.
>> Yes.
>> I used--
I'm very--
>> I hate this right now.
>> That doesn't hit.
>> And the inspiration is only for one attack, right?
>> Yeah.
>> That's my turn.
>> Okay.
>> You try to strike a wall out of the air.
You move in.
I'm assuming you're moving in.
Are you doing it through the actual arms?
>> As your actual arms start to punch a wall.
The aura around you kind of changes as the anger grows inside of you.
And black lightning strikes out as it hits the wall.
He seems surprised and kind of taken a back by this hit.
But the second hit he kind of sees coming as he dodges that.
And it's going to be your turn.
At the end of your turn, the armor is going to make his legendary action.
And it's going to--
It's going to again drop down.
Can you make a strength save?
>> Train.
>> So you can change it with wisdom, I think.
>> Right, 20.
You can take half of this.
Okay, what the fuck, man?
>> It's a shockwave.
He's never mind.
I'm not going to try that.
No, it's bludgeoning.
So it's just two.
As it crashes again to the ground,
it fades straight through you.
And it's now burst turn.
Sorry.
I didn't want to do this, but this is what you are making me do.
Let me--
6.
Oh, my God.
Why isn't just rolling three, bro?
>> It's just three.
>> It's fucking three.
>> It's a way.
>> You're digital, but I read it on the three.
Now, he's going to--
Again, do three temp--
Sorry, one temp escape, not three.
Can you make a dex save?
>> Is it ranged?
>> No, no.
Not an attack or a--
I'm just going to make a dex save.
It's going to be slashing, so that's the--
that will be half damage, regardless.
>> By the way, it doesn't mouth this.
You never used it.
>> What?
>> He does.
>> Yeah.
>> He never--
He never got the chance to use it, I should say.
>> 2020--
1919 half is eight.
Eight half is four.
Oh, my God.
You're literally chipping down.
Everyone's chipping down.
There are two people fighting you.
Can't say if please.
Okay.
Your haste is lost as all these barrages of attack
just like whittled you down.
You're losing.
You can feel yourself losing strength.
Okay, Bob.
>> What is your move?
>> I said it a long time ago.
I'm going to touch--
By the way, how bad does the book tease look?
I am going to touch mouth first, but just asking.
>> Map tease.
Can you do an insight?
No, no.
Bob, Bob, do an insight.
>> Guess how wide I am.
>> Look.
>> Will it be medicine?
>> No.
>> I'm going to touch mouth first.
>> I'm going to come over here.
>> Can you change the indistern?
>> Yes, yes, yes.
>> Here we go.
>> Are you got?
>> So, and I'm going to come over here to my close friend mouth first.
>> And I'm going to touch him.
>> And therefore, so Bob wants over here.
And since his core is also kind of like,
he's going to put his core in his veins.
And he's going to like,
click his core and it will,
like, spray out fumes.
But like, filter fumes that are going to,
you know,
>> 20 points with the lay of hands.
>> You're using 20 points.
>> Is that the perfect one?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Oh.
>> And it's an action.
>> Yes, that is an action.
>> Okay, let me do a mouthfuls,
you're back up with 20.
>> And since my action is gone,
with my bonus action,
do I have literally anything to do with my bonus action?
Oh, I have this.
>> Yeah, this is not going to be very useful,
but I am going to pass.
>> What are your lives?
>> I'm going to use this.
>> That's my bonus action.
I am using my,
so my health right now deals in the chronic damage
with the amount of my charisma.
And that's my bonus action.
>> Okay, as soon as you do that,
we'll take his legendary action
as he looks back at you and goes
another crawler.
How many times do I have to make you understand?
>> You can't stop me.
>> And he is going to make another
legendary action.
>> Just like me,
when he says you can't stop me,
Bob goes, but he can and mouthfuls works off.
>> Okay, make a deck, say, Bob.
>> The only ability.
>> So,
21.
>> Well, as he spins around
and just throws like these air picks towards you,
it flashes your body.
>> And that's going to be his turn.
>> It's your turn, man.
>> So, you're back up,
you're conscious and you see Bob by your side.
>> I am grappled right.
>> No, no, you're not grappled.
>> I'm assuming Bob would like,
free him.
>> I want to punch for
all in the dick.
>> Give him some sloppy.
>> Okay.
>> 25.
>> 25 heads.
>> You're still rolling a private way,
really?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> What's the damage?
>> I don't see it.
>> Seven.
>> Okay, I see it.
Seven is going to
>> That sounds like he's back up.
>> He's not happy.
>> I used up all of my show for you.
>> Bob, but to be honest,
I am good.
>> I'm not going to be able to
get out of here.
>> I'm not going to be able to get out of here.
>> No. >> No. >> No.
>> 21.
>> Just wait a second.
>> What the hell are you doing?
>> If you're not doing.
>> 23 heads, though, right?
>> No. >> No.
>> No, no, no, no, no.
>> As he dashes straight back in, he tries to hit you with the finger bristles, all of them.
>> Yeah. >> Just move your shield up and block all of that.
>> Yeah.
>> And there's going to be his legendary action.
>> The Marines turn.
>> It's going to be.
>> He's going to charge the beam once more.
And let me see who will be the lucky guy to get fucked by the beam.
>> Oh, how? >> Sorry.
>> I accidentally moved you.
>> One, two, three.
Roll of fate.
Malphus.
I'm sorry.
>> That's the one that's on the wall.
>> You are the lucky one, it says.
>> Yeah.
>> Lucky.
>> Okay.
>> It's a blanket too.
>> 27.
>> What happened?
>> See if you can take half of that.
>> Yeah.
>> Can let's see.
>> It's like Miss Oral.
>> It's not an attack roll, so I can't really use that.
>> No. >> The blackness is only on the damage.
>> No, it's an attack roll.
>> Yeah, yeah, it's an attack roll.
>> It says. >> Ranged attack roll.
>> You can do it, but it's not supposed to be like that.
>> If you want to fight, you can.
>> When you are hit by any ranged attack, this is a ranged attack.
>> Attack.
>> Okay, sure.
>> At the start of the fight, you allowed it, so can we just do it?
>> Sure, sure.
This fight, sure.
>> Do you have the key points?
>> Yeah, I have to do more.
>> It doesn't take me.
>> Okay.
>> No, no, it catches it.
>> To revert it.
>> To revert it does, right?
>> That's max.
>> That's max, which is 14.
Why? It's going to be like six.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not worth it to waste the key point.
>> It's not worth it to revert it.
>> I mean, if you just want to like
>> Maybe just switch characters.
>> I won't kill Malphus.
>> We can just say that he's just gone
>> We can just say that he's just gone looking
>> Looking for
>> Looking for a way to do.
Yeah, he does not believe you.
That is not nice.
For me, that's nice.
Oh, it's healing.
44, the two ones and two and four.
All right.
Anything else? That's your turn.
Right after your turn, you're going to make another one of his bonus action.
Let me see if he regains the...
New?
Okay, he did, he did, he did.
All right.
It's five or six. Recharge five or six.
Okay.
It's like mechanically recharging, but you know, it's just...
Here's the tank.
Can you make a con save?
Let me check who is going to attack.
Roll a fade, baby.
Bob.
Bob, you die now.
Holy shit.
Make a con save.
I love how Roll a fade literally says Bob died.
You died?
Yeah.
We should just add a word message to Roll a fade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's going to be funny.
15?
It's not good.
You take full damage.
Well, I'm down.
You're not to roll.
I know I'm down.
It's not down.
I'm just checking if you're dead or not.
Yeah, you're done.
You...
He's going to make his full movement and go straight through you.
As he just like humbles you with the Rock-U-Gone.
It's just like this shockwave just penetrates your body as he falls down.
Okay.
All right.
So...
Uh...
That's his movement and his action.
He can't move.
He's on the ground near Bob.
Uh...
Zero.
There we go.
Actually, I can use a bonus action, right?
Yeah.
Again.
He's going to sorrow.
30 feet up in the sky.
Again.
And...
There we go.
Okay.
As a Stern, Bob, make your dead save.
You can back at it again.
Many a while, huh?
As we get in with the white bombs.
Oh, nice.
Bob, just quiet.
Bob, you're up for one HP.
It's not good Bob.
I don't want to.
You can play that this time.
You already died.
You're not sure you're doing it again.
Yeah.
Everyone gets one chance to remake their characters.
You're not yours.
Don't abuse it.
Come on.
All right.
Okay.
You're back up.
Let's move.
Malthus, your turn.
I'm going to add your three, I guess, temperate points.
I see sort of pulls looking back at Bob.
Do I have to remember that?
Go, battle.
Where could we bottle?
Does that say 30?
Then he crashed down the hitbox.
And then he pulled back up.
Yeah.
He's right next to the ground with me, right?
No, no.
He used to use the word back up.
Okay.
As you fly up, he now 100% sure knows you're also Lunar in.
Looking at that in pressure.
Yeah, but now I know.
He's not in bird form.
The misses.
Yep.
The miss it.
Oh, this is a get off.
Two more.
One.
No shit.
Yeah, that's.
Can you.
Was it.
Contest.
Come on.
You saved.
Yeah, that's a.
Come on.
Yeah, forget.
All right.
Plus three, right?
So that would be 14 plus three that 17.
So he fails.
Let me pause up here.
Yep.
You will take the 30 feet damage, whatever.
It dropped damage.
36.
And what's your damage for the announcement?
True.
Roll the damage.
Yeah.
Seven.
And 36, right?
Even the ground has done more damage than me.
As you fly straight up, you take war by surprise because he wasn't expecting you to just fly up without transforming.
So you miss one head.
You missed second one as a third one.
And you're hand and close it itself with armament, hockey as you just burst straight through his armament, like, body, like armoured body.
As you just slam him right into the ground as he falls down, he takes.
I'm going to say he drifts like maybe 15 feet here and then he falls down here.
So he takes high as damage.
And there we go.
Oh wait, Bob, you came back up.
And he is.
Yeah.
Stunt.
Then I don't need to do what I was thinking of doing.
I could hit once more.
If you wanted to heal me, I'd love that.
No.
You remember when I was on one HP and you decided not to heal me.
But I could have healed you anytime.
Doesn't hit.
I just want to give you this.
All right.
Does he land prone since he hit the ground?
How many attacks have you made this turn?
Well, it's an event because he's done.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Yeah, it does it.
Ten.
Yep, that's me.
All right, that's your turn.
Baptiste's your turn.
I'm coming.
He's coming.
Baptiste's a season ball up in.
He's like, that's my chance.
It doesn't have one miss.
Yeah, I know.
He is doing with advantage.
That's 20.
So yeah, I was best if you roll normal and happen.
It's fine.
The second one will be in eight.
So that's plus seven.
26 plus seven is 33.
One more.
Is he still up?
Yeah.
Well, no, he's done.
Road.
That's a one and a 20.
Okay.
This is like this is like all men.
Oh, holy shit, you actually rolled two eights.
Holy shit.
28.
Yeah.
I think this is the universe.
This is the universe giving us a signal that borrow dies.
Come on.
I can't.
I can't just make his head fee zero.
That's how it works.
Just play it out.
Yeah, yeah.
It's one and okay.
Now you want to pay it out.
That's three, right?
That's all.
All right.
Come on.
It's your turn, Bob.
Oh, shit.
I don't think anyone.
It's a guy.
He's turned.
You got advantage.
I really, really, really hope.
Bob.
Yeah.
It's your first one to check the waters.
19 doesn't have.
Nope.
Yeah.
This is like that scene in justice.
21.
21 does it.
20.
Doesn't it.
Are you shitting me?
I am shitting you, Bob.
It doesn't.
I'm not joking.
And would that let me just let me just let me just.
Yeah, that's what I was about to say.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Plus or plus or.
Why is it not in the spell list?
Oh, it's not a spell.
Never mind.
I forgot everything.
Kakashi by any chance could like borrow the F.E.
End or an undead.
No, he's not.
He's a human.
He can see.
And Bob's eyes.
So that's.
10 21.
And I get 4.
Wow, I am so down.
Yeah.
That is my turn.
We got to tell yourself.
I don't think we got this, but.
Okay, Malthus.
Come on, you're stunning straight.
Come on.
That is the one.
Your turn again.
Oh.
You get that.
You would have managed.
Oh, my God.
Okay, you have to kill him.
If you don't kill him now.
No, he doesn't got the role.
Because he's still stunned.
He is stunned.
Yeah, he's still stunned.
No, no, no, no.
I mean, as soon as it Malthus is turned ends,
it's he's not going to be stunned, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
21.
That's what I'm saying.
What's that fucking?
21.
Yeah, 21 hits here.
Right.
Also, Malthus still has one inspiration by, right?
I'm just saying, I roll the 1D6 in advance.
All right.
Eight.
Yeah.
Spanum.
Okay.
That's the one.
Another one.
It has it.
Of course.
Six, eight, 14.
Another one.
Why is blood not showing up on this token?
I'm very--
I'm counting all the damage that you're doing at once, right?
There is blood on the token.
Yeah, there's blood.
The Lord has much as us.
Yeah.
Okay.
It doesn't hit.
You're using Flurries?
Yeah.
Okay.
Over to the Manage.
Does it?
219.
Please, please, that was 219.
Wow.
Please, I--
Eight.
Come on.
Okay.
Malthus, I need you to make a wisdom save.
Oh, no.
17, okay.
Uh.
Okay, so I'm going to recount her everything that has happened.
Malthus, you saw an opportunity as soon as a Warro downed Bob.
Bob, you somehow managed to get up still.
Malthus, you dashed in, smacked him out of the air.
He landed straight on the ground.
Baptiste, you saw this opportunity as you dashed in, and you hit him with your full strength.
Bob, you went in with your halberd.
The first one missed as the other one just slashes him straight through his--
like, a right side through his chest.
Malthus has, like, all of this--
and all of you are, like, beating him and just trying to, like, just put him down.
You, uh, finally, like, game composure as all of your heads just doom, doom.
Slam him into him.
And he looks up at you, Baptiste, as he stands in the middle, all bloodied.
At this point, just blood gushing out.
His body completely, like, deformed by, like, all the hits, all the punches and everything.
You see his mask kind of crack and fall down.
You see the inside of his mask?
It's fine.
He looks like a normal person.
There's nothing weird going on with his body itself.
But he-- but you do notice something.
As he-- as the-- as the life snuffs out of his eyes, you do see him smile
as he looks back at you one last time.
He goes, "This is in the end.
I will be back."
As he falls down and just--
Well, I was knocking on my-- I wanted to knock him out.
It's not made for me to decide, "Death."
Please!
No, no. I was counting up, like, the damage you guys were doing, so he's actually dead.
Well, but I wanted to do non-leafle. The last one.
Please, my office, I beg of you.
Okay, I'm going to give you a last option. Do you want to do non-leafle?
Well, his damage is not made for me to decide if I just knock him out.
And--
No, I'm asking--
You're knocking him out. You're not doing any lethal damage, right?
Okay. So he falls unconscious instead of dying.
Yeah, let's say that.
Yeah.
I was assuming you were going to kill him, but if he's knocked down--
No, he's not this guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I get it, I get it.
Roma.
If you failed the wisdom saving throw, I would kill him.
Yeah, but--
That's why I asked you to do wisdom saving.
It's back to you again now.
What?
I can torture him.
Get it tortured.
All right, after this--
It's up to him, like, cuffs something, but--
By this point, by this point, all of the guards that were like with the cart has--
have like left, run away, just left the cart there and ran away.
So you have the access to the wagon. You have the access to Boros' car if you want to take it.
And it's up to you what you want to do.
I'm going to switch back to Roma and we'll continue from there.
Okay.
Roma, what are we doing?
From the prison now.
See you.
Okay.
You and Linus are like waiting for the commotion to maybe simmer down a bit,
but the noises above the cells are still like coming through.
There's still a bunch of chaos going on around.
So what do you want to do?
It's been five minutes.
We run it up the cells.
And I'm going to be like, because since I let the prisoners go,
I should kind of remember which cells are what.
So I'm going to leave him--
I'm going to leave him back to that room.
Oh shit.
Where--
Where I-- no.
What-- oh shit.
Where I knocked out that dude, you know, where I walked into the hallway
and I had the two options until you either go down the steps.
All right.
You see Linus kind of like shuffling through all of the like the lockers
of these guards to try to get some information out of it.
And nothing useful comes out of it as he looks at you and goes either way.
So then I'm going to be like, all right, upstairs leads to that open court room
where you saw me, bro.
The bottom half is where that ship is.
How do you want to do this?
The bottom half is this ship that you saw.
Did you see any other ships except for that one?
Oh, it's full.
It's full.
But all those dudes jumped off the main ship that's at the pier or docked,
whatever you want to call it.
Well, it is a warship.
So I am assuming that there will be some sort of sea stone locks around or on the ship itself.
So I won't be able to face through it.
So I'm just, are you sure that whoever's you're looking for is in that one?
Because there have been multiple of these warships that were brought.
You said that those guards are borrows personal guard.
Yes, they all came from that one ship.
Okay, so we go in then.
How do you want to do this?
I'm in sub 2.
All right, let's go in.
James Bond style.
We go with two.
Tell me down the steps.
You sneakly go by.
Can you make a shelf roll?
Oh, shit.
I know this shit.
I think that's going to be better than mine.
Oh, we're stuck there.
I'm a puppet cloud.
Okay, you make your way down to the ship.
What do you want to do?
You want to just enter the ship?
You see Linus kind of like touches like the like she of the front of the ship to maybe see if it's made out of sea prison stone or not.
He as soon as he touches it, he kind of stumbles and backs away and goes, yes, sea prison stone.
I thought it would be well, we go in and we better be sure that we can find a way out.
Let's go.
Okay, he turns around and grabs one of the ladders to try to climb in.
Okay, are you following us?
Okay, you follow him.
You don't see anyone on the ship at this point and you don't like figure out like you figure pretty quickly like all the people that were on the ship just left behind you.
You can maybe search around.
Can you do an investigation?
Linus is going to go in one direction.
Okay, look, the brig is usually on the bottom side of the ship.
So maybe go down and check.
Okay, let me do another investigation.
He calls for you from the other side where he was looking for.
He calls for you for the Roma, I think I found her.
And I think I was looking for the same person I suppose.
And inside of this like dimly lit cell, unlike a chair, you see a woman just like tied up and just bloodied her nose, bleeding like broken nose.
And there's like blade like cuts all over her wrists and face is like also like pretty beat up.
You see like a black eye, stuff like that.
You can figure out from the way that she's sitting, that she was like being tortured for whatever reason.
And can you make a wisdom?
Can you make just a straight intelligence check to see that you remember who she is?
I really hope I fail this.
You remember a girl.
Yeah, you remember that she is the girl.
I still need to find bravo.
I have to find bravo.
So at this point, I'm pulling up my phone to old Baptiste.
By this point, the fight would have concluded because it is like eight rounds.
So it's still under one minute that all of this happened apparently.
So Baptiste.
So just like breathing heavily.
Yes, Roma.
Why do you sound like you just had sex?
Maybe I did.
What's the view?
Why is something like you just having sex?
What happened?
What I miss?
I was like, "Duck, duck, they just..."
They said bravo was there.
Is he down?
Is he okay?
I mean Baptiste.
Oh, you okay, boss?
Yes, we managed to win.
Oh, he fucked him up.
Hey, duck, he said he fucked him up.
Good.
Try to keep him alive.
I need some help.
Everyone can hear this.
Duck was looking for a...
What's the name of the name?
Yeah, it's him.
He was looking for a symbol.
I think...
You're looking for a symbol.
We found her.
I'm still looking for a dragon.
He's someplace on the ship we're in.
A dragon is being transported here.
No, they said he was already here.
His execution was supposed to happen.
One week from now.
He was on his execution before hers.
Hers was first.
It was her hearing.
And then a week after it would be...
Okay.
I found her.
She's pretty beat up, boss.
Somebody fucked her up.
Hey, duck, she cocks us.
She kind of looks at the cage and hesitantly touches the edges of the cage.
As he touches it, he again lets it go and steps back and goes.
We need the keys.
From this point, I think she's breathing.
He says things.
She's breathing.
We need the keys here.
I'm going to reach in my pocket.
I'm going to throw him at the dock.
It won't be the same keys because those were the guards at the place.
It won't be the same keys.
Linus tries the keys.
It doesn't work.
He goes, "It's not working.
I'll try to look around.
Maybe we'll find some."
I'm going to go, "Boss, hold on.
Give me one second.
Be smooth and rip this door off."
Okay, Roma hand me the machine.
Yeah, you take this dock.
Okay.
What are you doing?
I'm going the hybrid mode and then trying to rip the door off.
It's made of what do you call it?
Seaprism strong, so you can't, yeah.
As soon as you touch it, it will sap all your strength.
I'm still going to try it because I'm Roma.
I'm just going to be like, "What the f*ck?"
Yeah, as soon as the roles are all doing my work,
as soon as you try to punch it,
you just fall down because it just saps all your strength.
Linus just looks at you and goes,
"What Roma I'm going to talk to Baptiste for a while?"
You figure it out, as he just steps out.
And while you are talking to Linus Baptiste,
you hear just Roma just beating the door again and again and again.
Roma, can you just every couple of seconds just keep rolling?
Okay.
So you also hear Linus kind of shuffling through drawers
or like tables to search for the keys.
And he goes, "Right Baptiste, so, how do you know this is him?"
We found her when we were sailing.
She was drifting in the ocean by herself.
I thought you were...
Well, let's just say we have some friends in common.
Are you talking about the six votes?
She mentioned it before.
Well, the person that she's talking about
and the person I'm talking about doesn't really exist.
So I suppose we are talking about him, but...
I've heard the story about...
Yeah, well...
I was also looking into the device that the Marines are building,
but apparently this is what landed her in this place.
I felt kind of guilty.
I did find a way to maybe prolong Sapplius life.
He is safe for now, but we'll have to come up with a solution soon enough.
I think the next place...
We should go, it's probably so.
Try to make a way to the new world and look for Sapplius.
Again, I don't have any way out of this.
It's good that I found you.
Anyway, I think you also are looking for Drowman Rice.
Yeah, he's...
They said he's not coming in for a minute, but...
It's fine.
You should be arriving soon.
I was snooping around and I overheard some of the Marines talking.
He is supposed to arrive tomorrow with two other Marine captains
from different squadrons.
Of course, I would expect no less from them.
They are very cautious when it comes to my target.
I bounty targets.
Anyway, I think I found it.
Linus looks around, turns around, and at this point,
in 1826, 21, 23, holy shit.
Okay.
The way that you were just beating into the cell,
it's just inch by inch, punch by punch,
it actually just broke completely.
You are dog tired.
You just fell back on your back as you were punching through.
But as soon as Linus turns around and he finds the key,
he goes, "Oh, what do you know about that?"
I suppose we can get them out and meet you somewhere.
Do you have a place that we can meet up at?
Our ship.
Okay.
Where is your ship docked?
We're going to make it.
We're going to fight through all these people.
Oh, fuck, I'm tired.
Oh, I take four rows of water.
Well, Zora Ma, we can't take them like this.
There should be some free boats on this warship.
We should just take that.
Did you not see the cavern?
We can't get the ship out the cavern,
because there's all these other ships.
This is not a cavern.
This is like open sea where you are.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's just suggesting take one of the boats and just leave.
All right.
So we take one of the boats and leave it?
Yeah.
Just leave and find your way towards the other edge
and just hope no one spots you.
Okay.
Let's do it.
All right, that's it.
Just tell me where.
Where is your ship docked?
I'll tell him where he's docked.
After I'll probably deliver.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll tell him where he's docked.
So where are we?
Okay.
As soon as you start speaking,
go right to my TV.
What?
I'm sorry.
I was talking to my wife.
No, no, no.
I'm talking to my wife.
Who's in a friend?
Yeah.
I see.
All right.
I will.
Maybe there in maybe 10 to 20 minutes.
It's not that far from here.
Make sure it doesn't cause problems.
I'll try.
The Dendan Mushi clicks off.
He hands you the Dendan Mushi as he goes in and steps like around you and goes in.
Grab Zim and he looks at you and just taps you on your belly and goes.
I throw my time to go.
Where are we going?
Well, that.
There should be one ship.
Some ships around the worship.
Just drop one in the water and we can leave.
Do I got to row it because I ain't got it.
I ain't got it in me.
No, no, I can do it.
Okay, Doc.
Let's go.
All right.
So I'm going to switch from his perspective to yours now.
Okay.
So what's the plan here?
How are you going to go back to your ship?
Yes.
Let's.
I want to take boros car.
Mm-hmm.
I have to take his car.
No, we have to go back to that mansion.
Yeah, his car.
Boros.
What?
We need to lock him up.
So do you have handcuffs anywhere?
Or something like that?
Did you have?
I mean, the Marines should have the handcuffs or inside the handcuffs.
I guess he broke it.
Yeah.
The Marine, the armored Marine, he should probably have handcuffs.
And there would be handcuffs in boros like vehicle.
I want to do that.
I want to strip boros.
Okay.
Can you make an investigation check?
No slide of hand.
Why?
What are you doing?
I'm trying to find it.
17.
Okay.
In his pocket, you find the same kind of like telecommunication like then in mushy, a phone mushy,
and another radio mushy.
This is not the one that you were using.
You find those mushy's and you find his like black colored then in mushy as well.
And you find like a bunch of like information about like the routing that he like plan to get them here.
You find the routing of draves and the people who are escorting him here.
One of the names on the sheet is Commander Leon from G9 unit and Captain Dress Crown for G45 unit.
And then the other one is the one that you find the most important thing to do.
Those names are any bells for anyone?
No.
No, no, I don't think you would have known any of those people.
So is he should make it right now besides his underwear?
No, you're getting a badass naked.
That's for later.
All right.
I'm wearing a ticket under there.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Nothing else on him.
I'll go over to the other.
Bob, do you want to try taking over this armor again?
Again, now he has literally any.
He is a intelligence is even lower.
What do you mean?
Yes.
Uh, DM.
Uh, also the armor is probably like completely like torn apart at this point.
Oh, never mind then.
Because like I wanted to upgrade the current armor that I was wearing.
You can you can take it, but you will have to take it to someone who is experienced in making armor.
A blacksmith or something.
An armor.
An armor east.
Something like that.
Okay.
I want to go loop the.
What can I move?
Can we get out of combat so I can move?
Yeah.
I want to go loop the armor.
Find the handcuffs.
Anything else he might have.
I was muted, but yes, uh, Bob is also going to do the armor like the armor itself.
So that guy is also stripping.
Again, his armor is like completed torn apart.
You can get like pieces of the armor and let's like bring them with you to maybe, uh,
like integrate them with your armor.
Yeah.
Nothing, nothing else will be on him that his only purpose is to fight.
So he doesn't have handcuffs.
The guy would probably have handcuffs like it's attached to the armor.
And this guy and worst car probably.
Yeah, I mean, you have to roll to investigate the worst car if you want to.
Who's investigating?
Oh, okay.
Oh, look at his car.
Bob is going to help and by help you mean guidance.
So 24.
How hope for doing that, and it.
Before.
Do another one.
We'll take the higher one.
Okay, 20.
Yeah.
So you look around in his car, you find a couple of things that you find like a big,
great, uh, not like big, like maybe like a small box, uh, essentially with like a bunch of like, uh,
serums inside kind of the same serums you saw back in Calisto.
You see a white one, a black one, a green one and a red one.
Four serums.
Uh, uh, the other spots, there's spots for 12, but you only see spot these like four that are still there.
The other were our empty.
Like I label them or what they do.
The serum say one of the serum is called 033.
The other serum is serum 11.
The other serum is serum 44.
The other one is serum 99.
Uh, the 33, 33 one is white.
11 is green.
44 is red.
99 is black.
Take them all.
Romo will take them.
Other than that, you just find like a bunch of paperwork regarding the other, uh, sites that moving industry is associated with.
One of the sites is called IO.
IO.
IO here we go together.
Rats of team.
Europa.
IO is marked in the south.
Europa is marked in the west.
And, uh, the two are going to Jupiter and.
Ganymede is marked new word.
And Calisto, there's, there's a paper of Calisto and it's said being reconstructed.
Okay, now we have to figure out who can actually use the car.
Who can do that?
This is new tech. So none of you would have any prior knowledge.
What would it be? Can you roll? Just straight intelligence.
It's not an animal. Just straight intelligence.
It's all one person.
I mean, you can add the guidance.
It's a kind of trip. He can just spam the guidance.
On a hit, God. I have no idea.
I have a better idea. Bob. Bob, can you drive?
That's all just right. Bob, can you drive?
Can you get that bottle giving your guidance?
Yeah. Yeah, but it was.
Bob intelligence.
Okay, roll for guidance.
It's not going to work. Even if it's like for highest one is baptized.
Roma hasn't rolled yet. Roma hasn't rolled yet.
You got here. What do you mean?
Give it first.
So you try to start the yet you're trying to find like where the hell does it start from?
Do you want to put a borrow inside first or do you want to just try it running it first and then maybe put it in?
I mean, we'll be under the assumption that we can probably figure it out.
So we can end it up. Okay, as soon as you just like props or a borrow inside the vehicle starts to just automatically turn on.
Yeah. And like a small like wheel kind of pops out.
Baptiste you can figure out the rest.
Okay, so.
So all of you would would not be able to like fit inside.
So some of you can just like latch on on the outside to travel.
Essentially, or would be inside. Baptiste would be inside and.
Maybe Bob is more is yeah, restrained and handcuffed and put at the back of the back.
We get.
Okay, so you are going to the mansion.
Okay, so you turn the vehicle around and go back to where the mansion was and.
Okay, you arrive near the gate of the mansion. What's the plan? What are you doing?
The plan.
This carpet on our ship.
You need to get it through the door of the mansion through the whole mansion down the stairs.
Yeah.
Hold on.
How far how far is like the stairway down from the entrance where we are.
It's just like literally a near like the stairs of like the main stairs of the mansion.
There's just a small corridor that leads downwards to the docks.
Is there like water nearby besides going through the mansion?
I mean, yeah, there will be like small ponds, but that's not like it's not going to connect.
How do you how do you suppose all the fucking devil fruit users are going to make out of the water alive?
I just want to know if we could.
How it possibly could bring the ship.
I mean this part.
You arrive at the door. The gates are closed. What do you want to do?
Run them down.
Mouth is fly ahead.
To the ship.
Intel Cade.
To prepare to leave.
Get your drive closes through the shore. So no father.
And I'll do that.
What do you like at the line or something?
So where are you flying off?
Around the coast.
Or somewhere I can take off without being.
So you fly up and you're using the cave entrance to go in, right?
And get to the ship.
It's going to be a while.
Tell you like get there and like tell everyone to move the ship somewhere else, but you already told Linus that the ship is there.
Just so you know, are you telling people to move the ship or what do you know?
Yeah, get ready to leave.
Okay, you're telling them to get ready to leave. So Baptiste, what's the plan?
The ship is left.
See, I really want this car.
Oh, you can't get this car.
You're living the sea.
Yeah, I mean, we have a car.
We have the horses.
A very recognizable car, by the way.
Everyone knows.
Yeah, everyone who knows were over now.
And we're going to be able to get the ship.
We're going to be able to get the ship.
But realistically, how would you carry it on to the ship?
I guess you can put a big wooden platform, a ramp to drive it in.
That's right.
I mean, you can.
You can.
How to get the car to the ship.
Yeah.
Any ideas, Bob?
You're on the Europe behind the wheels.
My only idea is to drive through the mansion with it.
That's not what I'm talking about.
What?
There's a lot of people.
This is a roadkill.
How long has it happened after our fight?
Probably like 10, 20 minutes.
I love you.
Okay.
So there's no water connecting to the back where the dock was correct.
That's what.
What said.
Okay.
And the only way to get tired.
The ship is going through the mansion down the stairs.
I'm not sure if I can drive through the mansion.
I mean, you can.
The door is in the mansion.
You can drive around it.
How wide was the corridor leading to the stair of the door?
I mean, the car could fit in like barely like it would be scratching the walls of the of the stairway.
I'll take it.
Do you want guidance?
Let's do it.
You guys are what?
What are you doing?
You said it could fit.
So we're going to make it fit.
M.D.M.
10 betties smoke.
I mean, he can take the head.
I have a pretty good bond.
Again, it's his decision.
Do you want to get high before we do this?
I'll do it.
Just do like.
Yeah.
To get the head off.
Like, but you see that piece is thinking about something like you see the idea going in his head and you operate or he looks to take it.
He blows the pipe and then just steps on the gas.
All right.
As you step on the gas, you just ramstry through the gate as the guards like kind of like go like run away from the vehicle as more and more guards that are like trying to stop it.
Just jump away like just roll away essentially.
And near the door, you see a man in like a blue coat and like with a baby blue coat as he on his other hand, you see like this small flute as he just snaps it as it turns into like this long baton.
And he's going to run toward the vehicle as he takes the baton and just stabs it in one of the wheels.
He can't do anything.
You can't do anything.
Do you have a reaction?
Yeah.
Here's what I'm thinking.
Can I have a shield like I have the spell shield can I get my shield in front of him and like can I get out from the window get my shield in front of his baton and the wheel like deflected.
I will be burning one of my spells.
What is your bond?
It will give you advantage.
It's about each other next to.
Yeah, but this is more important.
Yes, it is.
Good thing.
This is like BMW.
All right. What are you doing?
I am intercepting the attack with my shield.
Okay, you can intercept the attack.
And as you like maybe turn around and maybe start a stand in front of the vehicle as baptism is like through the whole he's kind of like trying to navigate through the door of the mansion.
You see the guy just clashes his staff clashes against your shield as he looks at you and goes.
And what are you lot supposed to be doing here?
Is this the butler?
What? No.
This guy is burning side by side with the car going full speed.
He's not side by side.
He's literally in front.
He just jumped on the car.
And right now it's him and you Bob and you're still driving into the mansion.
Let me put you Bob and him into encounter.
I do not have the HP required for this.
I don't either Bob.
You know, let's do this.
I do still have the bone right after Baptist hit it.
I took it back.
Bob.
This is the guy you messed with.
Yeah.
He's back.
He's mad because he was running your car through his mansion.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You didn't know you were related to romance.
No, I said he's back here.
He would be back here because of the outbreak yet.
For sure.
It's your turn.
He doesn't look that strong.
Oh, he looks strong.
You see this guy is like kind of Aish maybe around in his 30s or something early 30s.
He's just cheering down at you with his staff and yeah, he's just not stopping.
He's kind of pushing you back.
So Bob is going to like take a hit off his bonn and go.
And then he's going to cast text on this guy with his bonus action.
And this the main thing it does is give plus one D6 to damage.
But the additional thing it does is choose one ability when you cause a spell that target has disadvantage on ability checks melody with the chosen ability.
And he is going to have disadvantage with strength.
And then with his action, he is going to grapple this guy.
Then let me just let me just I am doing everything with one hand because my other hand is eating.
Very sure.
Too late.
No, borrow still has his underwear on so nothing else.
But are your underwear on?
Hey, make a strength check.
I think we got an answer.
Yeah, we did.
I think the grapple is.
I think the grapple is is.
It's show of athletics because I really need this.
Yeah, yeah.
Show us.
Okay, okay, okay, I'm showing it.
Show him off the car.
Essentially, and he kind of rolls to the side.
And you.
At this point, you are like in front of the mansion.
You're not quite in yet.
Okay, that's your turn.
Wait.
I'm not going to get it.
He was like here.
Let's say both of these guys are here.
He shoved him off.
So he's now here.
I'm here somewhere.
You should have something up in front so I could run him over.
You want to run him over?
Okay.
No, no.
You said he was to the side.
So we'll play it like.
I mean, I don't know fucking Bob knows.
I don't.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm assuming on your turn, you're just going to step it.
You're up.
Yes.
Okay.
As you step it, the initial like bump of like the stairway leading up into the mansion is going
to slow it down a bit.
So you're only going to move around like 30 to 40 feet.
That will get you to the like the threshold of the mansion.
You'll have to still turn around and as soon as you go into the like hallway where like the stairway,
you'll you'll considerably slow down because they at this point you're just grinding against the walls.
That's fine.
That's going to be.
Yeah.
That's your action.
Can we do anything other than like like, like, on the walls or something to make it faster because I don't believe that guy's down yet.
Of course.
Of course not.
Why would he be down?
Okay.
Yeah.
Bro, it's not easy to navigate into like a house.
Okay.
Would you mean a car only as if you're going to move it?
But we knew this would be difficult.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can't expect everything to go like smoothly.
Okay.
This staff will definitely hit the car.
23.
You can shield if you want to, Bob.
But it's still gonna think my self between yes, I'm putting myself between him and the car.
Okay.
You're at 19.
Just running around on top of the car.
Do you know I have my reaction shield. So that's 24.
You have spell slots left.
Yes.
Okay.
First of all, I have two first of all spell slots left and shield.
It just doesn't use spell slots. It's also my creativity at that.
So it has I have two uses of few.
Okay.
One of them.
Messes again.
How much is your AC?
24.
Okay.
I'm gonna hockey this.
And it's gonna be.
26.
Right.
23.
26.
Yeah.
That is.
It just goes through your shield and he's aiming at the wheel.
So it will stop the car.
And at this point, you will crash into the wall.
It car can move with three wheels.
Yeah, but you're still going to have problems maneuvering the car.
What the fuck do you mean?
Can run us to your wheels.
Yeah, but you're gonna crash into something.
Are we in the quarter at this point or the?
You're in the mansion in the mansion and you crash into one of the walls of the mansion.
Can you guys take roll to these six?
Seven damage.
No saver anything.
No, what?
What do you mean?
There's a save.
Zero.
I'm down at three.
And remember I did five on myself.
I did not edit.
Oh, I see.
So what was it?
Three.
Okay.
Baptiste.
I'm at 11.
You are 11 now after taking damage.
Yeah.
Right.
You're slammed into like the side of the wall.
You'll have to use your whole action Baptiste to maybe like maneuver it toward the way that you came in essentially toward the steward.
Or you can step out and fight.
Real decision.
No.
Make a concept.
This is one of those sessions where Roma doesn't nothing.
Well, nobody got that.
That's fine.
Because I did everything last time.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you're what's not no longer.
What was the concept for consuming gloom right?
No.
What are you concentrating on?
Oh, the hex is not up.
Okay.
That's fine.
What was it on strength?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's fine.
All right.
It was his turn.
So after that, Bob is your turn.
Let's get my turn.
No, it was his turn.
Oh, I'm lost.
Yeah.
It was his turn where he threw the his like the staff that he threw.
And Bob reacted.
And that's why it's his.
Bob.
Bob is going to use his second level spell slot last second level spell slot to pass.
Where is it?
Please find it.
There is.
Why is there two types of casting?
Have no idea how this was.
Let me just do this and cast this spell.
And this is aid.
And what aid does is it increases the target hit points maximum and current hit points of three targets by five.
So Bob, Ben, Baptiste has plus five to hit points and Bob is going to get hints.
Yeah, that's that that's his turn.
And he's going to take the dollar.
8 HP you read H HP.
Yes.
Oh, yeah, no.
Never mind.
Yeah, that's his turn.
So you just give five HP to you and Baptiste.
That's it, right?
At least.
Yes.
Eight of tees it at 19.
All right.
Is we got it.
We got up cold.
This man.
If we go down, this is.
Okay.
Past and curious level of thing right now.
This guy doesn't look that small to that teased.
That's the same time I'm like.
If we stay here too long, we just want.
So if I can't get rid of him quick is like.
You know what?
I have a bonus action for things like this.
I want to know his HP.
He just know his HP.
That's what it's like.
Okay.
Is it is it HP?
I think it was just AC and everything.
It does say.
I think.
Four decks of court.
Constitution intelligence wisdom charisma armor class in AC.
I can choose one of those.
Okay, hit points.
Okay.
I didn't see hit points.
Yeah.
He has 91.
Okay.
So I can't get rid of him in one turn.
I'm going to use my action to fix the car and keep moving.
All right.
Next is his turn.
And.
What?
I'm going to use my action to fix the car.
Maybe I should have killed him.
This would last for a bit.
Oh well.
Would I have heard the commotion?
I mean, we literally step on the gas right after mouth of the left.
So he should.
Right.
It's your mission.
Yeah, that's his action.
Yeah.
He like kind of grabs the staff that was like thrown off the.
The wheel and he grabs it.
He like turns it as like a big shockwave kind of burst through it.
As it like breaks a bunch of like paintings around the wall.
But yeah, he just like starts to run after it.
But at some point he just gives up as you just like zoom through the bottom of the.
Stay away.
I'm assuming Bob you're not going to just stay back and just fight him off.
Right.
No.
You're on the car.
Okay.
So Bob, it's your turn.
What are you doing?
You're just taking the dodge action.
Just taking the dodge action.
Okay.
You take the dodge action.
Baptiste, you're just stepping the gas.
Yep.
Okay.
You can see like him at the top of the stairway looking down as you speed through.
And he kind of just at one point just turns around.
All right.
You're at the bottom of the stairway.
What is the plan?
Is it my turn again?
No, you're turned.
You waited for your you read the bottom.
There's no turn.
The combat is over.
Oh, yeah.
I have guidance to that please.
Okay.
So now we have to figure out how to get the ship.
Well, the cart and the ship.
You would have like some some ramp on your ship.
Probably.
They keep going.
Yeah, but it won't be down.
You will have to inform someone to like put the rundown.
Oh.
As it like the noise of the vehicle like may come through.
You see Cade at the top of the ship.
He goes captain, you're back.
Get the ramp.
Okay.
Right away.
He runs toward like the side of the ship as he like kind of like.
You know that the rotating.
Whatever.
Right.
The chain thing.
He like lures the ramp.
And it like extends to the edge of the dock.
And you can try.
Climb like bring the vehicle in.
I would like to do that.
Okay.
But my mouth is around this time.
You also have made your way inside.
And you land at the top of the mast.
The crow's nest.
Okay.
What's the plan?
You want to wait for the line is or what we're doing.
Let's go closer to the entrance.
Okay.
So at the same time, you see the.
Mouth.
Cade signals you to maybe pull the ramp in as he goes to the helmet and starts to move the ship.
Yeah, I'm going to do that.
Okay.
Cade turns around the ship as you hear a bunch of noise coming from the stairwell.
As you see a bunch of guards starting to come down and point their guns and just shoot at the ship.
I want to.
Lapse the.
Well, corridor.
Okay.
Should the fireball.
Fireball or fireball.
Bulls.
Bulls is not going to do it.
Okay.
But that's going to take turns, right?
You can only shoot one at once.
Hey, time is.
It takes time to get the ship out of here.
Okay.
Roll one, the 20 plus four.
19.
Okay.
10.
So that's.
The five of the shots.
Okay.
Five.
Five out of five of the shots are going to hit people.
Okay.
Right now on the ship we have.
You hit my dog.
I'm hopping off this.
Hey, hey, hey, don't be a hater.
Hey, don't forget the saber to.
Yeah, but it's not under the back.
He's not going to be just piercing through the fucking.
The ship itself.
Hello, dad.
Okay.
Someone's taking double damage.
I don't know who it is.
Five five.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Five seven.
Oh, one, the eight.
Eight is cade.
Seven is Malfus.
Okay.
I'm going to just pick out of Bob and.
Malfus, you get shot twice.
Yay.
And.
It's been very good.
You got 100 points.
So 14 to Bav Teest.
Hold on.
Can I have to flag missiles?
Yeah, yeah, it's a good.
You can.
Seven to Bob.
You're at Waih H.V. Holy shit.
I'm always.
Seven to Bav Teest.
So.
You're at 20, right?
16.
What happened?
There we go.
And one's going to headcade.
Uh, Bav Teest 12.
Uh, 14.
So it's just two, right?
Let me over the damage that I did to you.
Undo.
And then.
Two damage.
Right?
So.
All right.
Okay.
There's no gas.
You could have taken the kuda burst of gray.
But you didn't.
I told you.
But it just.
Yeah.
You did.
You did have time.
It's just going to be like too much money.
And you have to refuel.
So you didn't do it.
Uh, so you turned around, uh, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, cave kind of like turns around the ship.
And it's your turn.
What do you guys want to do?
First of all, first of all,
Bob is going to call.
There are like five people like continuously shooting.
And you also see the, uh,
the guy that was fighting you to at the back.
You're just kind of looking at you.
He's not doing much.
But by this point, it wouldn't make it to collapse the stairwell.
Porter, right?
They're all outside.
Yeah, yeah.
Also a sense there are like,
we are the target.
So Bob is going to call his horse and the mound that was serving as a horse is going to come out over.
And it is going to serve as a.
Like a, uh,
cover for a.
Oh, wow.
Oh, uh, cover for Kate.
Yes.
Uh, I have one question.
Uh, did,
since you said he hid all of us like,
did it need to, uh,
get past our AC?
Oh, wait.
I did, I did roll, right?
Yes.
19.
Oh, 19.
No.
Okay.
It won't hit you then.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
So plus five is seven is eight.
Okay.
I don't love me.
Let's calm down.
Uh,
all right.
I don't think any of you have more than 19 is he right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
the horse doesn't have a high AC right.
No, it has armor.
It does have a very high HP.
It has a very high HP.
Wait.
Do you not have armor on the heart?
Wait, let me see.
No, we do.
They were armor.
Find mount.
Find, find mount.
Uh, my, my horse mount has a,
a 15 and HP of 40.
So it has that.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
Yeah, that's the,
that's the, uh,
yeah, stat we're going to use.
This is because I was putting a,
uh,
it will be,
that's why I did one D8.
All right.
Uh, another wallie of charges will come in.
What, what are the rest of you doing?
Is there anything I can do?
Major armor on your dog.
Like speed it up.
You can, you can, you can, like,
maybe put like wind against the sale.
Somehow,
if you have something like that.
I have strength.
Can I just pull the cells out very quickly?
Like, no,
that's how it works.
It works using,
using wind, man.
Okay.
I'll try.
Is there anything I can do right now?
Uh, how much AC does major armor add?
It's 30,
but he has a minus two decks.
So it's just 30.
So his AC is 10 from 13, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, he doesn't have any armor.
It's fucking dog.
It's a dog.
Yeah. All right.
What are you doing Bob then?
Is there anything I can do to make the ship go faster?
I mean, it's up to you.
I'll be creative.
I'm not.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Like, I'm going to pull the ropes of the sale.
Like, quickly to make it get the win.
Okay.
I'll give you a help action to,
uh, help, uh,
what do you,
a paid faster,
yeah, to move the ship faster.
I will do that.
Okay.
Uh,
I'm going to roll navigation tools for Cade.
What are you doing,
Malthus in the me and wall?
I guess getting going up and seeing if they shoot again.
Not like that.
I'm just going to get under you can get below deck.
Can you like,
like, uh, get a rope of tied to the ship and pull it?
He is not having a good time doing the,
and do the, uh, check whatever.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I have to do it with the advantage.
Sorry.
Yes.
Please, please.
Carpenter tools.
God, I have to bring his,
broken in.
Yes.
I'm for your life.
For teen.
Yeah, he should be able to like maneuver it a bit quicker than usual,
because you're helping like, uh, setting up the mask and everything.
Uh, okay.
Malthus, what are you doing?
Are you going to do the back of the ship and trying?
I don't know.
Not to get shot.
How about?
Uh, let me roll one day, 20.
None of these will hit any of you, right?
No, no, no.
Uh, blah, blah, blah.
On the six, but it will, it can still hit the ship.
So I'm going to just going to roll five, the eight, see if it hits the ship.
Uh, what's the ship's, that's the average.
It's not going to hit even you, right?
So I'm going to go six, three, three, five, five.
Oh, it's not anyone.
Okay.
I won't even hit the ship.
All the shots just with past each and every one of you.
Uh, wait, the target is 1D nine now.
Okay, no, man.
I forget it.
Uh, wait.
What's, uh, what are you guys doing now?
The ship is still not out.
Okay.
So you're sailing, you're sailing in front or you're turning back.
That makes all the difference.
What?
You're turning back outside or are you still sailing in within the cavern?
You because you said you're turning around.
So turning around will take a bit longer.
All right.
No, we're going to the entrance.
We're going to the entrance like turning around, right?
Well, did we go into the entrance and we stopped because we couldn't go anywhere?
No, no.
Again, you came into the cave like the side of the island.
You came into the cave.
That's the entrance.
And I said that there's a path leading in further, but there,
there, you saw this stairway leading up and you decided to stop here.
Okay.
So I'm asking, yeah.
So let's say let's say this is this is where you came, came in, right?
Can you see it?
Can you see my cursor?
Yeah.
So this is where you came in.
Essentially, there's a path leading here and this is the stairway.
So do you want to go here or do you want to turn around and go back outside?
Guys, here's what I'm saying.
Can we since going forward makes us go there quickly?
Can we go forward first and like get a bit of a distance so that they don't hit us or there's a bunch of
problems with this.
You don't know what's in front.
First of all, yeah, second, you told Linus to meet you here.
You told him to meet you here.
If you go back, there's a chance you will see Linus again.
If you go forward, then he'll have to still find you.
Again, there's like a more communication.
Yeah, yeah.
We still.
Yes.
You can still contact him.
Yeah.
That's why I'm calling Roma.
There's a significant risk in going in front.
I'm telling you this right now.
We need to turn around.
We're not going.
Yeah.
No, but.
So there's still going to be two turns until you're completely out of here.
I will call Roma on turn just to.
Roma is moving.
Raa.
The ship is moving.
We'll go around the north side of the south side of Allen.
Do you know where we're at?
We're headed toward the entrance where Malso has told me to go to.
We're headed towards you, guys.
I never said you my name.
I'm going to tell Roma what I told you told him.
I think he did.
He did.
I did.
I said I call you Zapdos.
Yeah, you did tell him.
The cave entrance correct.
Yes.
All right.
We got some heat on us, but we'll.
Try to run into you guys.
You got some heat on you.
What you mean by that?
Like.
Are you here breaking the.
Yeah, yeah, just just.
Yeah, you hear gunshots from like the background noises through the dead end moushy.
And it's like these dudes getting us into doc.
Well, I just hope that they will escape.
Now they ain't going to escape.
We got we got we got to have to fuck shit up.
We got to fuck shit up doc.
I'm just letting you know.
I don't know.
You're going to have to fuck shit up.
Okay.
Oh, let's try to make our way there as soon as we can.
So he starts to roll the ship faster at the boat faster and faster.
Is Roman not helping?
No, it's awesome.
I beat the shit out of that gate.
Remember?
It's still a boat.
It's not like the the way it is like not causing a lot of problems.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he did break down a fucking a sea of prism stone cell on all of his own.
All right.
So you want to just end the call here?
Yep.
All right.
That's his turn.
Bob, what are you doing?
I was talking on the phone.
Anyway, Bob is going to help pay.
And if anyone else is helping, I'm going to get him started.
Oh, what?
I also want to tell Buddha below deck.
What?
Below deck?
Okay, okay.
Doesn't get shot at.
Okay, Kate, like quickly turns around, like moves some of the like mass and ties it up quickly.
You see the mass like at this point is completely like full and starting to move at with great speed outside around this point.
You see them bringing in like a big cannon toward the ship and they will try to shoot that can.
They brought a cannon down the stairs.
Yes.
You brought a gun.
Yeah.
One, the, what was the damage for a cannon for God?
Yeah, Roma definitely would have heard me yell brace rein pack if I saw a cannon.
Yeah.
40.
It was a cannon hit.
Yeah, it will hit the ship.
Now, let's combine the black missile.
The black cannon ball.
You know what?
If you want to, you can.
I'll give you that.
Yeah, I'll give you that.
Come on.
Yes.
Oh, wow.
11.
I really didn't.
Oh, hey.
19.
You know, that's not bad.
So that's what?
30.
It's still not going to deflect it.
If you were able to deflect it would be very cool.
You try to essentially maybe like.
Come like maybe break the cannonball.
But it's just like, is it going at way too fast speeds?
It's just with us past you and it's like.
You know, you can't really do that.
I'll give you like.
One of them can like decrease the damage.
But again, I just wanted to do it in case you guys were able to deflect it.
That would be cool.
But you can't.
So I'm going to give full damage to the ship.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can try it.
Okay, that's going to be.
560.
Oh, it is 60.
Your ship has 600 HP.
So I put it down to 560.
Yeah, but you still have one more.
All right, what do you?
They're going to just do the same cannon.
Yeah, but that's what the action is, right?
Yeah, an action to reload.
No, the action is not really come on.
Is it time to reload the cannon?
Is it?
Let me check.
Yeah.
Well, anyways,
we'll see if Kate rolls well,
then you don't even have to worry about the cannon.
Okay, I'm assuming you are.
Okay, yeah, this should be good enough.
As a kid like turns around the ship,
you're at the like literally at the edge,
where you like start to see them like getting too far away from you.
So now you're leaving off on the from the entrance of the ship.
From the cave.
All right, you're out.
Do I see you room around somewhere?
No, no, you don't spot him right now.
It's probably like maybe there you guys are probably had like halfway away from them.
You can maybe meet somewhere in between.
All right.
So Voro is still inside the car.
I'm assuming.
Oh, yes.
Yeah, let's take him out.
You drag him outside.
He's still like quite big like around like seven seven seven four seven five.
So it's going to take a while for you to like just drag him.
As you drag him out of the teeth,
what are you doing with him?
You're tying him up somewhere.
What is happening?
Yeah, I'll be out of the table.
Yeah, I'll just tie him up in a room.
Okay.
You do have the saber tooth cage.
The server is inside the cage.
They were to the kill him.
The lock their saber tooth up in your bedroom.
No, what the fuck?
Get a destroy.
Yeah, you could do that.
Take a take a look.
Take a look at your head.
You already knocked out the man.
Now you go take a stick.
I'm worth it.
Let's do it.
He started this.
Yeah, yeah.
So you take him up to your room.
You tie him up in on like a chair or something around his back.
And you just unconscious still.
You can take this moment to maybe rest up.
Rest only short rest, not long rest.
Oh, I'm fine.
Yeah, anything.
The only one who is like fully prepared is Roma.
I'm not fully prepared.
I still have I'll take a damage.
Yeah, I got shipped by that bullet in the show.
Yeah, but that's not compared to like these guys almost dying.
Oh, 100% like I haven't even gotten close to half hell.
Yeah, you're 47 HP.
I know what the hell.
I just healed back.
All right, let me.
Short rest.
Kate as well.
Well, shit, if we all short rest in, I'm going to be full help by the time I get back.
Yeah, you're also going to short rest because you're not, you know,
rolling the ship or the boats are.
Bob recovered 43 hit points.
Now this recovered 27.
4 hit dies.
30.
Is it not going to work in short rest?
Oh, let me, let me bring your token.
And I think then you can.
There you go.
Now you can.
I think I think what are you saying?
Angel dies, you saying.
Yeah, but why is it only given me little as an option?
Are you not in?
Can you not use this one?
No, you're not on the right one.
I think you're targeting.
That's just it.
I'm selected on Roma like I see.
All right, let me do the short rest.
For some odd reason, my person is Lou.
Oh, I think because you, yeah, you were on the token.
You know what?
Roman.
How about now?
You still can't.
There we go.
Roman is just the Husky is the actual brain behind it.
Can you use it now?
Short rest.
Yeah.
Do not want to recover HP.
You have to check.
You have to check auto spend.
dice or just press roll. Yeah yeah. Chroma Max. Jesus Christ. Yeah. All right. I still laugh. And I got through that entire encounter, by only taking like seven hits. Yeah, I mean, you were lucky because Linus was supposed to be in Lexan period.
But look at all this shit I did. I broke up a guard. I talked about me.
Honestly, if any of them spotted you through the transponder snail at any point, you would have been looking killed.
The spot.
But that's a, but nobody nobody spotted me. Yeah. Yeah.
All right. And like 30 minutes or so, a Kade would spot your boat coming towards you as he points toward to the boat and looks at mouth as he goes, I think they're there.
Yep. So he kind of puts like brings the ship to a halt. You're kind of away from the island. So no one spots you. So you can maybe like stay here for a while.
But yeah, you'll have to move around. Yeah. The patrols would be out looking for you soon enough.
All right.
What's the line? Well, I'm gonna get my fat ass up on the ship.
And I think Linus is going to join us with Zin. Zin. Yeah.
He calls on to this ship and goes, well, I need some hand with bringing her in.
Oh, jump down. Yeah, you jump down and he looks as you can go. So you're a mouthful.
Oh, you can call me a good friend of your captain.
Get me on the ship. I gotta cook something. I'm hungry. What about you?
Are you guys bring Zim and she's still unconscious? So where do you want to put them?
Totally in the room in the bedroom.
All right. Who's room?
How many of you have one room? Okay.
Except for, except for Kate. Yeah, Kate doesn't have a room. Yeah. So you can bring her to Kate's room.
Well, no, Kate is in my room because we didn't have a room. Yeah, Kate's, but it's now Kate's room.
Yeah. All right. You bring her. Uh huh.
What rooms do we all have in the ship? So we all have four bedrooms.
Yeah, four bedrooms in total. You have one kitchen. Let me, let me look at the caravan.
Gotta have at least a store room for like ingredients.
Yeah, but you were taking one of the rooms when you were injured for your scientific discoveries.
Oh, so you don't want to room anymore Bob? Okay. So you're, you're reassigning.
I'm not sure.
Bob in the like school or something. What?
Like when we first came in into that this space wasn't boss hitting the school or something.
Yeah, but you didn't, you didn't get the ship in at the start, right?
You were in the spider ship in the beginning. Yeah. Oh, right. Yeah.
Just got this ship back. Yeah. He just got it back. And every time you get it fucking.
You know,
I fucked up. So if we have 50 million, I want to get everybody a bedroom.
So that's at least different. God, what time type of ship caravale. Okay.
G.
Roma has a kitchen. So we don't need to worry about that.
Mouth is what you like an navigator's room.
For the caravale, you can get two more deck levels.
You can get an expanded storage. You can get fuel tank.
And oh, you. Yeah, you can get the fuel tank and flight.
You can get two reds. You can get.
Yeah, bedroom individual bedrooms is two million.
Kitchen is already there. Dining room is not there right now.
Stages not there. Navigators room is not there. Sick base not there.
Library is not there. Training room is not there. Workshop is not there.
So right now you have four bedrooms, one kitchen. That's it.
Everything else you have to get.
Can we change the loop log to the ship logs? Oh, we can put everything there.
I want to. Yeah, you should have access to your ship. SSR caravale.
You can add whatever in this. You have like ownership of this token.
It's in their ships.
Go down and the under one shot their ships and then their SSR caravale.
Once in actors in actors.
You see the ship. I have B2. Oh, let me see.
Oh, you have defaults or out players owner save. There you go. Now you should see.
There we go. Alright.
You have one survival gun somewhere on the ship. I don't know where.
Whatever you want. Okay, we can go back to the story now.
I just want to get that off the way. Okay. So you put them in a cage room and
the yeah, whoever's true. And you put a borrow in yours.
Linus comes in and he goes, I'll take a look at them and we try to fix her up a little bit.
I'll be back. He had sin and he's going to take care of her.
In the meantime, what is everyone else doing? Roma is cooking.
And Bob.
If you eat the food, you all can add one hit die. Yeah.
I will eat Roma's food. Yeah.
Same Bob. Um.
No, I said he has eating Bob or Roma's food. Nice.
Do we have candles in the ship?
Who?
Candles.
To hope so.
Candles? Yeah, probably.
You trying to set a mood for war?
You're the
I'm taking a candle.
Rip and hot wax on it.
I am. I am. I didn't with my friend. Then start pouring the wax on to borrow your chest.
Really sick man. You dirty.
Uh, I'm assuming you're alone and just you and Voro in the room.
Yeah.
I'm excited for it. It's torture.
All right. No one else is going to join in.
I'll leave it to his private time.
Okay, okay, go go go go. Uh, all right. You and Voro on the ship.
Get it on the road. Yeah. Okay.
He's on a great freedom.
Let me make a short rest for him.
He's gonna come too. If you know what I'm saying.
Uh, what the fuck where is this head die?
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
All right. What the fuck was that?
So, uh, you haven't tied up. You start to pour the hot wax on him.
Uh, I'll say it's going to do like fire damage.
1d4. Okay. So you roll one three. Roll roll a 1d4.
Oh, you made a big mistake keeping me alive.
God, I just gave you what you wanted. You wanted me at the time, didn't you?
I'm ready.
Who what is this payback for torturing your little friend?
It's training. Training.
Need to learn.
I want to pour the wax again.
You need to understand your place, bitter bird.
You weren't nothing. Okay. Pour it again. 1d4.
See for a.
You're not in soul anymore.
You belong to me.
Yeah, it is.
You're going to learn that this is how it goes.
Do we have any other torture machines that I could think about?
All right. It's up to you.
You have two horses.
Why are we my dad?
You don't tie a rope around his legs.
I have a dark.
I thought I thought you were going queen Elizabeth where she used to tie the horses.
You can't. You know what I'm saying.
Around this point, you hear not at the door.
The way that it's me, you have to explain this.
You're going to come in. One second.
You're sending private time.
It's going in punching.
Boral to knock him back out.
Okay.
Do I need to roll?
Yeah, roll for damage at least.
You have to attack.
Holy shit.
All right.
Okay. He's knocked out.
I like open the door and as I'm opening the door about pieces of like
dusting his hands off.
Is him awake?
Okay. Well, we don't have a lot of time.
Aware that you're also here to rescue, drawing, yes.
Yes, he hasn't arrived yet.
It's that they were bringing him in still.
Yes, so the ship that he's arriving by lands here in three days.
And were there any witnesses to your fight with Warro?
Not to our fight, but to our escape.
The same thing he said.
Well, right about now, they would be wondering why Warro is not there.
Wherever you want.
I don't know where he was going to work.
And probably someone is going to contact him on his then-and-mushy.
So you mean that then-and-mushy now just point to his stuff.
Yes.
As you point to the stuff that you got from him,
line of seas like the stack of serums that are lying there around it and he goes,
what are these?
I'll hand them to him.
He looks at them and he goes.
How did they get their hands on this?
Experience. I suppose Niklai was not only working on Tapia, but also with the Marines then.
They're similar to ones you've run into before.
They morphed people into entirely new beings.
I know the origin of this.
Experimented on a friend of mine and they used his blood to synthesize whatever this
equipment is. Maybe I can figure out what these do.
I don't feel good about using their weapons, but at this point we don't have much options.
All right.
I have some questions for Warro. I'm sure you do.
You have your questions as well.
So let me know when you're done with him.
By the way, Zim is awake if you want to talk to him.
You can question him while I go speak to him.
I think it's best I have the right question.
He puts on his gloves. He takes out his surgeons' knives as he sharpens them,
a kind of rubs them together and he goes.
Don't worry. You won't die.
I'll make sure of that.
He spins the scalpel as he stabs him right in his foot as you hear the scream as you leave the
door and close it.
Okay.
All right.
Malfus, you should be near like the door when Linus left and he just tells you to keep an eye on
her.
Yeah, I'll later do them.
You're inside the room looking over Zim.
She's not talking at all.
Around this time, Baptis also steps in the room and
I heard Baptis,
after you, Malfus, if you want to talk to her, you can do it.
Who beats him.
I can't hear you.
Malfus, when we were fighting earlier,
Malfus looked like he wanted to die or like he wasn't pulling into the fight.
You was kind of how up Malfus, yeah, you can you can
yeah, he was crying but he has his peace like the rest of you know it's not a
he's happy as you know you're still looking for like the the others if there are skp's.
He would trust you with his dreams and stuff.
If you got what I mean, I want to have a conversation with Malfus first.
I want Zim to rest.
So take Malfus back outside.
Where are you guys having a talk in your room?
No, he should be in like somewhere in like the hallway where all the rooms are.
Oh perfect. So I'm on while I'm not knowing where they are.
I'm going to gather some extra food to see if people want more.
So I'm going to have like bowls and I'm going to be walking around walking into rooms
and I'm going to get to the captain's room and I'm all knocked open and see candle wax.
Fucking water.
We're getting a wax on him.
He's like this kinky motherfucker.
Right now Linus is in the room.
Yeah, and just like you just see like a bunch of like scalpers stabbed in
wore his body and Linus turns around and goes, you know what I mean, you need anything.
Yeah, I was going to see if you guys wanted extra food but you guys are obviously into
some kinky shit that I want to learn.
You got a candle wax.
You got needle play.
You got knife play.
Oh.
Let me see.
Come on.
Look at me.
I'm just going to stand over here.
I'm going to eat up against the wall.
He may be quiet.
Oh man.
Well, why is this pain that's still on if you guys doing this?
At least take it all the way off.
What you think it might be.
I'm just.
Hey, I'm not.
I'm just saying I see a dark room and there's only candles.
I'm seeing.
I'm seeing some things.
I'm I'm putting two to two together.
Okay.
I get it.
If you all want it help, why did you just let me know?
Oh, okay.
Shoot.
We could get Kate in here.
He knows some he knows some not tricks.
Him being a Helm's.
You know what I'm saying?
You mean that the kid?
I don't think we should show him.
Like, I think torturing is a bit too much for that kid yet.
Oh, it ain't torture.
Well, this is torture, but we'll say torture.
It's also pleasure.
I see what you all doing here.
I see what you all doing.
Do you need me to get some silk?
I'm falling some silk.
Okay.
I just need to know.
I'll get some silk.
You know what?
Yeah, do that.
Get some silk.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Yeah.
As you leave, you hear like the door like locked like behind you.
That cheeky motherfucker.
That cheeky old plug.
I knew it.
All right.
Okay.
Mouses and Mathy?
What's going on?
You didn't see.
Like yourself earlier.
Well, it's been some interesting days, let's say, like that.
Indeed it has.
What's going on?
I guess my mind is just now.
I'm in the right place.
Ever since I let her because I can't help it one or more.
Very more.
Do you feel Peter will never find her?
Well, maybe.
I wasn't in the North before and then we met.
good terms out she was here all along and no especially me now? and it was the line is that was true, I
best chance I didn't do so might be ready for you and I might just stay behind here.
He said that regarding an old friend Sapya. He's since earlier already, but
we're here so my priority is focusing on what's here and that's your system.
So until we find out more this is where we'll be. I'm not asking to
go with me everywhere on this world you say that might not even have an end.
Isn't that what you're learning in this old house?
Finding me into?
I just don't know that I'm ready to hear you again.
Not get that. But you know we picked up those serums before the ones that we ran into back on.
I don't I have no idea. I have no idea. I was there.
Yes you were when we all had our one-on-one B1.
Didn't you see that? Didn't you see that?
No, because he did polisto. There were one from polisto and I was there.
The DM result are those two different serums?
Which serums? That's the bell.
No, no you haven't tested them so you don't know.
But you said they were to like the same one from polisto.
Which ones?
The ones from polo.
No, which ones are from polisto? The ones that Voro has are different ones.
They're not the same ones from polisto.
Probably similar to the ones from Death the Bell of where the
Yes, the green five also in check it themselves.
Yeah, yeah, you see you've seen the green ones right?
And in polisto you saw some white powder
stuff. You you definitely saw the green ones because that's the one I will shot with.
Yeah
You could hear worried about your power.
You could always try using one of those.
We have linus now so
he can try to minimize his side effects as much as possible.
That should take the way out.
What did you say?
Yeah, that just takes that so one time solution and taking the easy way.
Maybe since Zem is not going to leave here again,
she might need someone to help her search for something and keep her out of trouble.
Let's see.
Well, if
I've ended the days up to you, but
just know I'll support you regardless.
Let's
get to the first and we'll see what happens then.
All right, then I'll go in to them.
You try to open the door and you feel like some sort of like wait behind the door.
As you open the door, you see Zem standing against the door.
She was kind of listening in to the conversation.
Belly, which is kind of wrapped up with like bandages that linus put on her arms
are completely wrapped up.
One of her hands is tied up around her neck to for support.
It seems to be broken.
She waddles her way to the bed.
He goes, "Do you hurt me now?"
"I am a spy."
"I do what I do."
Indeed it is.
All right, question.
How close is
Baptiste's room to this place?
I'm not that poor.
So before he gets into that, Rome is going to come running down the hall and be like,
"Hey guys, linus is a kinky freak. You got an acer--
Rome, what are you talking about?"
So, I'll let me tell you this.
I thought you wanted some extra food so I was going to come bring you some.
I knocked on your door, opened it up.
Linus got borrow in a candlelit room with--
he's cutting them a little bit.
He's dripping candle wax on the man.
Mind you, it's candlelit.
So it's very romantic.
And the man asked for silk.
So you know what that means, right?
We're talking brown chicken brown cow time, okay?
So, man.
Hey, hey, hey, miss me.
He kinky. I'm just trying to please.
Like, there was candle wax literally dripped on the man.
And he's slicing them up a little bit.
He's in a knife play.
I don't get it to each the room.
I just need-- you got any silk?
I got to go back.
But he just starts shaking his head.
But he is so disinpoignant.
You ain't got no silk.
Okay, let me uh--
Madam, you gotta--
Go find Bob.
Oh Bob got silk!
Okay, let me go.
All right.
Oh.
That was interesting.
Indeed it was.
How are you feeling?
I feel like I've been hit by a train, but otherwise I'm doing good.
More than before.
So close.
Thank you.
It was so close.
But he caught me.
I don't know how.
I knew I was going to be there.
Tell me something about this.
Sorry, that patient.
He's a cry.
Love a lot.
No, that's another love.
You were doing so good today too.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was doing so good.
God damn it.
Every, every fucking session broke.
Have you had someone that you cared for?
And then they just vanish.
Indeed I have.
That's your fucking idiot.
I don't even know that that thing, it does what it's supposed to do.
When I'm thinking that it's not with my only hope.
Now look at me.
Euceless.
I don't know why I even bother.
And who says you're useless?
You're the only friend I had I lost.
Only people I cared for are gone.
What am I even playing for?
Life is not worth living anymore.
Sorry, you said I'm just randomly.
What do you, who do you think we are to have come to rescue you?
You want to make our, it's your idea.
That's what you are.
You took on the Marines to save me.
Come on, Dante.
We didn't even know each other.
We met for 10 minutes.
And yet, you wanted a way to be paid back?
That's what we do.
I guess you did.
You don't know what your purpose is.
Didn't find it.
That doesn't mean give up.
Make use of the life that we saved.
You have your information.
It's always been there.
Strong, clean.
How he takes it.
To be connected to one another.
I said something with you.
You said something with me.
Believe it or not.
Whereabouts now.
Well, you may think that no one else besides your one friend cares, but
I think that's being here is proof enough that that's not true.
I suppose it is.
Thank you, Biltese.
Okay, I think I should be resting now.
I'll talk to you in the morning.
Just call if you need anything.
Of course.
She lies down.
Oh, you're the one.
You go the door behind us.
All right.
Okay, I think this is a good point to end.
We'll continue next session.
Yes.
The next two.
I will be in a different eight.
So the times are different.
Not guaranteeing anything.
We can move the time around maybe like an hour later than usual.
If you want to, it's fine.
We'll see.
Just keep us updated.
Yeah, just let us know whatever it is.
All right.
Also another second.
In the next week, my final service starts.
So for like a month or two, I have to go away after three hours of the starting time.
So we can yeah, we can trim down the sessions a bit.
That's fine.
Yeah, are you guys can continue that me in the later parts if there are no lights or something?
So.
Okay.
All right.
It works.